figure out a way to make this system
work better so that's what you see in in
the bill and what it does is IT
addresses the issues that arose there
um
which
tried to get at the kind of process of
transferring uh the wires and why it
takes so long and you know we learned
that it that uh one company can't move a
wire until the company above it has
moved its wire so you end up with this
chain of responsibility and notification
and work orders that go out we also
learned that it was very hard for
municipalities or others to enter to
understand the data system or have
access to the data system which can tell
them where what the situation with any
given poll is in there
municipality and then
um not everybody uses the so-called
engine system some utility to do some
don't and so would there be
communication between
the utilities who have different Data
Systems so that's what the um
that's what it's going to get at you'll
see the responsibilities here
um make the management systems work
better EG engines see if we can get more
people to use it and see if there's a
way of providing access to
municipalities so they can get real-time
information on what's going on there
um
also uh look at the poll identification
and poll location information so that
it's clear as to what is where and what
needs to be
done see if there needs to be any
changes to the rules under the puc
regarding poll transfers that might
facilitate this process so the
stakeholder group is set up by all the
people who wanted to participate it'll
be run out of the Department of enter
a department of energy we heard from the
person who runs the program the
enforcement program
there and so that that there it is I
know that representative can provide you
with a lot more background of the issues
but this is the way we think we can get
out the problems Mr chairman
wonderful thank you senator for
introducing this bill to us are there
questions from the committee
representative Harrington has a question
more of a comment I'm looking at a
picture here that thankfully uh Mr
Licata is taking care of this for me but
there's a hunk of pole we probably can't
see it that's been hanging in the air
for about four or five weeks now those
are all telecommunications not electric
cables on there but if anything
reinforces the need for this bill just a
pitch is worth a thousand words and I'll
shut up
I will say thank your question
representative Harrington I won't
comment on your willingness to be quiet
but uh
um I will say that uh you know I hadn't
really thought much about telephone
poles right it was on his committee and
then you know you start driving around
your committee and it's like oh you're
commuting oh yeah there there there and
uh and we also heard from some private
landowners some Farmers for whom this is
creating a real problem in their land so
it'd be good to get at it yeah thank you
Mr chairman okay representative Doug
Thomas has a question thank you Mr thank
you for taking my question Center
welcome uh during the last summer when
they were having the committee meetings
and so forth was there a sense of um how
many uh objects around the state that
are would be considered ones that were
either abandoned or hadn't been taken
down yet are we talking any numbers come
up or just a general sense yeah I'm I'm
sorry that I don't have to thank your
question I'm sorry I don't have that top
of my head but I did the one thing that
did stick in my mind was that when we
had a storm in 2022
from that one storm there were 800 poles
that needed to needed to be replaced so
whether it's just you know the normal
aging or needing to put in a higher
pulse or more wire
um more transmission wires can be put on
it or other other wires
um uh there are hundreds and hundreds
maybe I maybe representative Grody has a
more figure but there's a lot of them
out there
a lot of them out there
okay additional questions from the
committee representative Noel has a
question
thank you Mr chairman thank you senator
for taking my question is there an in is
there an informal understanding between
the the companies that they can share
polls with each other or is that a
formalized procedure uh that's a
question that's a formalized procedure
and we're going to hear I believe from
um folks the enforcement person at doe
and uh potentially utilities I don't
know who else is signed up for that but
a lot of those questions can get
answered but the short answer is yes
thank you representative McGee had a
question yes thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question thanks
for being here
um this may go to other folks on the
committee but it sounds like this group
is going to be looking at uh coming up
with some decisions around what needs to
be done in terms of addressing some of
the lagging maintenance that hasn't gone
on but will there also be an effort to
address going forward being able to
Chronicle what's going on because it
sounds like we've maybe let things get a
little out of hand to answer the
question that's why there's so much here
about engines and the data systems
because you know the there there really
were two issues better coordination
so things can get happening be happening
but then to do that
better and more shared information and I
particularly liked that information
shared find some ways that municipality
is going to access to the engine system
and more people get access to it so that
so they can know they can report they
can understand and get back to people
who in the community are complaining
about it and say Here's the schedule
here's going to happen and I have some
accountability on the schedule as well
and I think there's really a great
willingness among all the people saying
yeah we need to get together and have a
group to make this happen and I think I
think they'll succeed
thank you representative Bernardi has a
question
thank you Mr chair uh
uh Senator is there any uh um evaluation
going to be done as to whether or not
some of the lines should be buried or is
this just going to focus on polls
thanks for your question
um this is just about the polls and you
know the utilities
you know I I think in terms of their
whole transmission system that that's
something they're empowered to look at
all kinds of Alternatives but this is
this is the polls thank you
representative Thomas has another
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for indulging me one more question
um uh well I'll just feed off what I
just heard from representative Bernardi
if this is just about polls I hope it
would be other extraneous things that
might have been associated with me maybe
they were one time hanging on them and
now they're just drooping over uh I hope
they would focus on something other than
just polls when practical my question is
um
is there a sense when we when this group
gets together and comes to an agreement
with how they're going to handle this is
there a sense that this will all happen
without any cost to the rate payers
um thanks for your question you know I
uh
I mean the the the polls are replaced
and the work is done already right it's
just we're looking at the efficiency and
the quickness of it so
um you know their re transmission costs
are recoverable charges
and I mean at that this bill changes
nothing about that
and I don't expect to be any I'm I don't
see any increase they might even Save
Somebody because then get the work done
more quickly
yeah representative munz has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you senator
for being here
um I have just a question on the
specific language in the bill line 14
says that uh there will be two members
from investor owned New Hampshire
Electric utilities is that two members
from each utility or two members in
total representing the utilities
I'm two total okay that's the way I read
it okay and follow-up follow-up
um do you have any sense at all
um how many how large this stakeholder
group would be based on
the the people that are going to be
members
seem seems very large
that's okay I know I'm putting you on
the spot
I go looks like to me like we've got ten
okay members all right now I just did
the count okay thank you looks like we
got 10.
these are these are the people who
wanted to be at the table
representative Carmen has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Senator waters for taking my question uh
can you fill me in a little bit more on
what sort of centralized database there
already is that the utilities are
tapping off of or you know what what is
there and what what further is needed
centrally
um well there is the the largest ones
the so-called engine system you'll see
it referenced in the in the bill and um
you know or another centralized system
information sharing so that not all the
utilities use engines
so there's more than one and there's
some critiques about whether engines is
the best or whether it needs to be
improved and so on so that's why we kind
of direct this
um this group to look at that issue of
what's the best what upgrades might
there needed to be so that the goal of
being able to communicate better and
having more transparency and I hope
providing real-time information to
municipalities and others who who want
to know and and when I say
municipalities what I would imagine is
that you know somebody who has one of
these on their land or outside their
house or something like that
um could contact the municipality in the
municipality would then be able to get
access to the data system and thereby
communicate with the with the utilities
that have to do the work
but I think we'll hear more about this
from some of the other folks follow up
yeah so so just just so I'm clear so so
the State of Affairs right now is that
there really is not a single centralized
database no and and that would be
perhaps one of the desired outcomes of
all this work
you know a single one or wants to
communicate could communicate with each
other I mean you know there's a lot of
ways to get the same thing done we just
want to get it done
representative closure has a question uh
thank you chair thank you Senator Waters
taking the question has there been any
discussion on uh abandoned lines from
Pole to pull and to Consumers I
understand a lot of the old cable lines
are still up
um I'm just thanks for the question I'm
not sure the best I'm the best one to
answer answer this uh and I just don't
recall whether we got into some of those
other issues in the in the um study
committee or perhaps representative
Grody or some representative utility
will be able to address that
representative that's a question thank
you Mr chair
the the polls that we're discussing here
are polls in the distribution Network or
does it also include polls in the
transmission system
uh uh I'm not sure I can give you the
right answer on that follow-up
I'm I'm from Berlin and the co-wash loop
runs through there and currently ever
source is working on that that's why I
asked the question yeah
um thanks for the question and I I think
that we are talking about distribution
here because these are you know these
are the wooden poles not the towers
okay seeing no further questions I want
to thank you Senator waters for
introducing this bill and I'd like to
call next on representative Jackie grody
for additional information about this
bill
and her perspective welcome
representative thank you thank you I'm
Jackie grota I recognize I represent
Rockingham 24 the towns of Ryan
Greenland
and um I would like to thank this
committee for passing House Bill 169
last year that led to this commission
over the summer the commission met
several times and
um the attendance was very strong and if
you'd like I can send you a link to the
reports and the minutes of the um
Commission because it might help address
many of the concerns that you have
there were three things that we needed
we felt as a commission that we needed
to address one was the customer
complaints that people had with double
utility polls in their area
the other was the difficulty that
municipalities had in learning in about
how these poll situations were being
addressed and then thirdly the
communication between
I'll say the providers on the utility
polls
utility polls are owned by
uh
electricity providers
so they each have poll ownership
and they allow
um through agreements the use of their
telephone poles of their utility poles
by Cable telephone
fire alarm companies
and these all this is registered in the
database called engines
and most utility companies use engines
as their database
however the difficulty comes in when you
have a pull replacement and tickets are
issued and then unless that information
about that particularly that particular
service provider switching their poll if
that information isn't put into the
system
then it doesn't trigger The Next Step
so there's this difficulty in actually
inputting the data in the system and
keeping it fresh
so rather than
um legislation to address this what we
chose to do because the participants in
the commission were so eager to solve
this problem because they've recognized
it as an issue as well we put together
this task force it is large because it
represents everyone who's involved in
this industry and they all wanted a
voice in it so we're hoping that
um through their as soon as this
commission is as soon as this task force
is established they're ready to get to
work and the um and Mr
the individual from the Department of
energy and their individuals from the
utilities are here and I would certainly
recommend that you ask them questions
but I'll be glad to address any concerns
that you have
thank you representative questions for
the representative
representative Noel has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
good morning I'd like to ask my
previous question about the transmission
it doesn't involve transmission lines
thank you no
and it really only addresses
utility poles
that's the focus of the task force
representative Doug Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question I'm looking at
the bill here and I I don't see a Sunset
date in it is is there is this supposed
to be an ongoing task force for forever
or is it something just to establish how
the utilities are going to work together
and to get this job done I I'm just kind
of curious if this is a perpetuating
task force or not I would think that
this task force is going to be meeting
for quite some time because the I think
the task force will govern itself
and um I did not think of a Sunset date
when we put the bill together so that
might be a question that you could ask
um Mr krasker from the
Department of energy perhaps but I don't
see this as something that this is not
going to be a quick fix this is going to
take some time
to address thank you
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman uh so the engine
system as I'm understanding it uh
some companies use it some companies
don't and part of the problem is the
system is not routinely updated when
work is done correct is that correct
correct and engines is a national it's
just not dedicated to New Hampshire
engines is a National Database that's
used by many utilities so it's you know
it's designed and it hasn't been
redesigned in a long time so it could be
that the needs are different because
this issue of the double utility poles
is not unique to New Hampshire
follow up
follow up uh thank you uh so which
Utilities in New Hampshire do not use
engines
I remember correctly it is in the nose
but I remember if I remember correctly
Unitil does not belong to engines
thank you
additional questions
you off the top of your head know what
the acronym
nj-u-n-s stands for
um no I don't remember sorry okay
I'll ask others thank you Mr chairman
it's a representative Reynolds has a
question National joint utilities
notification system ah you found that
good thank you thank you
okay seeing no further questions we want
to thank you representative for taking
time out of your day to be here to tell
us about uh this bill give us more
explanation thank you
we have one more pink card submitted for
this bill and that is rep Mr Griffin
robarge from
uh the department of energy also with
him is Paul
esper I think
so welcome gentlemen
give us your perspective on this
legislation
uh thank you members of the committee
um for the record Griffin Roberts State
energy program manager at the department
of energy with me today is Paul Casper
our director of our enforcement division
the department is in support of Senate
bill 16. um as has been previously
mentioned the Genesis of this bill uh
comes from a study commission that was
formed last year through representative
grody's House Bill 169 that study
commission met a handful of times
between October and November of last
year and this bill is the product of
that study commission as you'll if you
read the reports one of the
recommendations
as broadly as possible the bill creates
a stakeholder group within the
department to address utility poll and
attachments the stakeholder group will
look primarily at improving
Communications amongst poll attached
poll owners and attaches and addressing
the functionality of current
administrative Rule and state statute
and then toward the bottom of the bill
you'll see that per by November 1 of
every year the department has to submit
reports to the legislature about the
stakeholders group and again with me
today is Paul from our enforcement
division he's our director and I'll let
him speak to the need for the bill
good morning everyone
I guess to start this just to give you
some perspective of the issue of double
polls double polls are created in two
ways
one of the ways is to make ready work
and this is where
there's a either the electric utilities
uh the Telcom utility those are the two
entities that normally own the polls
they own them either separately or
jointly
in their petitioned by fiber companies
that are coming along even towns that
want to put fire alarm up and they come
across a certain number of polls that
aren't tall enough to create the amount
of clearance that's required so the
utility weather electric or telephone
will set a new poll
and the first one to transfer is always
the electric companies they do it both
instances it's the electric company and
this is where engines kicks in now
Unitil isn't a member of engines they
didn't join it but you know till
contacts anybody that's
attached in their service territory or
in on their poles or joint polls and
notifies them we've transferred at such
and such a location you are next
the the other incident that creates
double poles obviously are accidents and
storms and some one of the Senators
earlier talked about the storm well this
past storm that we had uh just a couple
of weeks ago
it damaged 700 poles
so let's say that out of those 700 500
now a double poles
because they don't always replace
the damage pull sometimes it's just
damaged enough with a set of new pole
and again I want to make it perfectly
clear when a new pole is set the
electric company transfers immediately
because they require it to
and then the process begins it sits it's
they're waiting for the next one down
generally it could be
um cable TV it has a tendency to be the
next one down so they were all notified
through engines if they belong to it
even though they belong to it doesn't
mean they're going to do it
that's just a mechanism for them to all
use
and I could and I can just tell you from
my own experience just being the
director of enforcement I get calls
constantly
customers towns there's a big problem
somebody asked about how many are there
it would be a tough guess it's in the
thousands or tens of thousands
just in a through say a three block
radius around this building I could take
you out and probably find you ten double
poles
that have been there a while it doesn't
transfer quickly I actually have a fold
here with photographs I had sent one of
my inspectors out a while back he found
a double poll that's been waiting 12
years
for a transfer
and the reason was we couldn't get in
the gate
this is over in the Hampton Beach area
it's interesting our employee found a
sign on the fence called the number on
the gentleman that had the key to the
fence came right out and opened the
phone
we contacted Consolidated Communications
because for the last 12 years they
couldn't transfer it because they
couldn't get in there
so and this is not please take this not
as a finger point
uh I've had several meetings there's
several States throughout the country
where we meet on teams periodically uh
in my counterparts and we talk about
issues common issues among states number
one issue double polls
and uh one of the states uh the state of
Washington that how they addressed it
they brought everybody to the table
probably in a similar manner what we're
trying to do
they got all the utilities in Washington
to agree that
um especially the telecom companies that
they would there's one particular
contractor that they use that transfers
everybody
takes transfers it and pulls the old
poll what they refer to on the business
as pull the butt out of the ground so
this is only one pole left in
everybody's transferred
it's not easy but it's certainly taken
care of
the double pole issue we in one as one
of the Senators this just we have triple
polls out there
and I I guess from my perspective I'm
passionate about this uh it's a safety
issue
it's not just because they don't look
pretty
but eventually you know what happens is
how they how they do this they a poll
gets hit they send a new one and they
send it as close together as possible
and it's and the old pole might be
lagged to the new one on lashed with
lashing wire
well if you're waiting too long so
what's a reasonable amount of time that
we should expect that pulse to be
transferred
12 years I think that's excessive myself
how about even a year
but even two years
this lashing gets deteriorated
in fact
my partner here came in one morning and
had pictures for me of a poll that he
drove by on the way to work that was
dangerously leaning over the road
and I contacted the utility and they
went back out there to show it back up
so there
that's the biggest issue besides you
know the Aesthetics you know I believe
that representative grody's committee
everybody was at the table and I don't
want to be unfair to the utilities
because I look at all the utilities and
you know 97 of the time they do an
excellent job
it's that three percent that we we
really watch and work with them and this
is one of those cases if we can bring
them to the table come up with the
solutions yeah engines is one of the
solutions
but if everybody joins engines
in just I just I applied for a license
to use engines I'm still waiting for the
response I applied three months ago
so things do take time but I mean I'll
be persistent
but I think if we get everybody to table
and come up with Solutions there's a lot
of attaches today and I'm sure a lot of
the utilities the Telecom Comcast will
tell you we have fidium now and Breeze
line and we have all of you we have
private fiber companies coming in so the
polls are getting crowded
you could drive down uh South Fruit
Street just outside my office window
counting it the other day there's seven
telecommunication lines on the polls
there
foreign
yes yes
and you go ahead and finish and then
we'll open it up to questions so it's
it's growing if somebody else comes
along now I'm sure unitil's gonna have
to put on loopholes along until Fruit
Street to accommodate the next one that
wants to attach
so it it it's it exponentially grows on
a daily basis and then when we it gets
exacerbated by storms I mean just as
past Stars we had you know at
Thanksgiving and Christmas and after
these last two storms we had
the winds take down you know we have 200
Pine 200 foot pine trees here when those
come down they do some damage
it we end up with all of these extra
double poles and they don't all get
transferred expeditiously so I guess if
we can bring everybody to the table and
start talking let's find a solution
there's a solution to everything but we
all have to agree to it and we all have
to put our heads together and say what's
the real solution is it engines is it
it's the commitment to using engines and
responding when you are contacted to say
you're next to transfer and go out there
and do it within a reasonable amount of
time
not 12 years from now
how about three weeks of a month yes
everybody has problems with resources
but but this is a real safety issue at
High
and that's
okay well thank you for that testimony
we appreciate you being here
representative McGee has a question for
you thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for being here I appreciate your time
um it it sounds like we really do need a
strategic uh approach and my question is
whether there is any federal money that
you're aware of in the infrastructure
act that's coming to states where you
said that this is a this is not a New
Hampshire exclusive issue right there
are many places where they're looking to
invest in updating and the maintenance
of the infrastructure as far as both
telecommunications and utility polls so
I was just wondering whether there is
any funding that's coming to states to
assist with this to help speed it up
I I don't know of any uh directly
representative but Bill you know grants
like you know
um the Broadband build out yeah that
would probably could be used for such
things
but the double poles that are created by
by you know accidents or storms that's
really on the utilities in in it's I
don't know of any federal grants for
that
um
sure
um there is some federal money in the
infrastructure Bill obviously for greedy
resiliency activities um and that type
of thing but I think broadly when you
look at an activity like this when it
comes to say you know enhancing uh
poll transfers in a more efficient
fashion I don't necessarily think
there's like an easy locked Federal
funding source for that but there
certainly is federal infrastructure
money coming down the pike for grid
resiliency activities and that type of
thing and to Paul's point there
certainly is a lot of broadband money
coming down and that will require you
know obviously the build out of
broadband the transfer of polls and
attachment attachments and you know that
could you know potentially exacerbate
the problem that we're that we're seeing
so follow-up follow-up and so the
follow-up question would be if this
um committee can pull together
planned activities than perhaps we would
be able to be eligible for some money by
saying here's what we're trying to do
right isn't that often how it works with
the federal funding potentially
obviously with federal dollars comes
Federal strings there are certain
activities that are eligible for those
types of activities off the top of my
head you know there's a formula grant
that's given out to States for grid
resiliency I don't necessarily think
this would be one of those easily
defined activities that would be
eligible for that funding but to the
extent this group is able to identify
something and and identify a federal pot
yeah okay thank you representative
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question this
goes back to the question I asked
Senator Waters is um
reading the bill here it there doesn't
appear to be any direction or provision
in there to talk about like what uh
representative McGee said cost and money
and and so forth
is there is it your
um
impression that maybe something should
be added to this to say the group needs
to talk about how how things are going
to get paid and hopefully not by the
ratepayers but if so how and when and so
forth and so on
um
maybe I I think you would probably sure
so
um regarding the the duties of the
commission or stakeholder group I'm
sorry lines 19-2 it looks like 28. I
would agree there isn't a specific Duty
there
um looking at Cost but I think the
duties are quite broad already
um to maybe Encompass a lot of the
different things that go on with these
types of poll transfers and that type of
activity
um and it's certainly I think the
Department's view in working with
representative Grody and Senator Waters
is we want to keep it as flexible as
possible to really get the functionality
of these types of issues and to make
sure Communications are streamlined
um it's certainly something we can
discuss about maybe putting in a
provision about that but I think
respectfully we don't feel there is a
need for that
um given the language
follow up yes thank you um
I would say yes but uh
um could there be something put in there
that would say that part of the duties
are to part of other Solutions is to
minimize any cost to rate payers or
anyone else because this seems like a an
issue that the utilities should have
been working on all as long uh you know
like if there's if there's if there's
storm damage that cost of course goes
into rate payers rates and so forth you
know you know things like that but now
we're talking about getting new data
management system in and the people the
utilities may have to pay for new
systems and of course they're going to
have to recoup that cost somewhere so
that's that's why that's why I'm asking
the question
representative I I guess I just want to
bring you back to
the I where the utilities do uh have
some cost recovery during storms that's
not the problem
remember I told you the electric
companies transfer first
they don't have a choice they have to
for safety reasons and it's just the
nature of it it's everybody else coming
down the poll it's those eight to nine
to ten fiber companies
um cable TV telephone
they have to come along and transfer
that's the hold up that's what creates
the double pull in the center that I
talked about other representative
mentioned
a small chunk of pole like this
hanging we call that chunky Pole
because that's a nice way of getting
around the transfer right
if cut the top off cut the bottom off
just lay this piece of
say about a three foot piece of the pole
left up against the new one
that's still a safety issue what happens
when it comes off the new pole it's
hanging there everything goes down low
again
that's not the solution the real
solution is
all of us getting to the table
thinking about how's the best way to fix
the problem yeah engines is is one it's
part of the solution
but the l i my personal opinion the
other part of the solution is the
commitment
to doing the transfers
that's what we just can't keep delaying
because again if if it's fine three
months six months
but once it goes beyond six it gets
forgotten and what happens every day
there's a new double pole or a triple
pole being added somewhere
so did I understand you to say just then
that once the transfer is made of all
the lines on the pole
the poll gets removed in a timely
fashion that's correct so it it's
removed by the poll owner whether it's
the electric company or the telephone
company comes back
pulls what they call the butt out of the
ground fills the hole back in it's done
okay great representative munz has a
question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
coming in and talk to us today
um you you you just mentioned that you
know what's missing is the commitment
to actually do the work that needs to be
done how does this change that
it's if I I believe bringing everybody
to the table and not it's not in a
punitive sense sir but to bring
everybody to tables they'll all
everybody admits it's a problem because
we're not the only ones getting the
complaint the electric utilities get
complaint the telecoms do the fiber
companies do I was in the industry for a
long time and I managed a service center
one of one of the towns that I had under
my jurisdiction the road agent refused
to allow me to set a poll again until
all the double poles were gone
it's like
this is how bad it got it it hasn't
changed in representative Grody could
I'm sure just other Representatives we
had the representative from Exeter
testified in and that was one of the
complaints from her constituents all
these double polls in Exeter
follow-up follow-up
I I understand and I I know of one
situation of a chunky pole in in my town
um and it's starting to hang
um but
um
I guess what I'm struggling with is you
know this is there's nothing that's
going to compel these members to come to
this meeting
um and there's nothing that's going to
compel any action
and so I'm trying to understand what
what will be what's different after we
implement this stakeholder group than
what could be happening right now I mean
there's no reason why these entities
couldn't be pulled together now I
they're clearly not doing it I guess
from my understanding the report that I
will have to present to all of you
I guess believe that December November
November 1
um would be the finding saying there was
participation there wasn't any
participation there was no but he really
actively involved wanting to find a
solution that could be my conclusion
that's one of them and hopefully I'd
rather be able to write you a report
that says we've we found this with these
are the steps that we're taking to
improve the process
again and these are this is just my
opinion sir it it's gonna take
Collective
getting together and and think everybody
coming up with a solution what's the
best idea how can we better transfer in
a more efficient manner than we are
currently
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chairman so if
correct me if I'm wrong on this my
understanding is electrical transfers
first and then all the various Cable
telephone fire department wires whatever
it is have to be transferred and each
entity that owns them has to do it one
by one is there an opportunity for a
third party to transfer all of the
non-electrical wires in some kind of
One-Stop move is that a possibility or
is or do we have legislation that needs
to be changed to permit that
I it it is a possibility it would be an
agreement under all of the let's call
them all the Telecommunications group
that's how the state of Washington as I
stated earlier my counterpart there
that's how they address the problem they
got all the utilities in and they got
the telecoms to agree there's a one
single contract I want a third party
comes along transfers all the Telecom
stuff
bills them all equally for whatever the
total cost was and in their particular
case this third-party contractor once he
has everything transferred he actually
removes the old poll takes it away
because little polls of hazardous waste
there's a cost to that
so maybe we can find some common ground
there with everybody in New Hampshire
thank you
representative Nutter has a question
thank you I run by one of those hanging
um pieces chunky poles yeah that's I was
going to ask you what they're called I
was going to tell my neighbor I thought
you said chunky monkey but you call them
chunky poles
in the industry the line workers call it
chunky pull when they cut off the bottom
and the top and they leave just a
section of it follow-up follow-up
comment
um it's been there since the ice storm
of 2008 the Canadians did this one
again
the Canadians came down and and helped
with the ice storm
um to reconnect all the power
so
representative pojo has a question
oh thank you chair and thank you Mr
Casper and uh Mr low Birch
Porter record I'm going to segue off
with this question our fellow
representatives in here committee
members that in section four
could
would the department of energy and
compliance
consider
coming back and report if there is Need
for legislation for compliance since we
know how committees sometimes work
I'm against it but in certain States
instances so would it that would be a
response thank you thank you
representative so I think I think the
way I think we took the reporting
requirement is that if there was
agreement amongst the different groups
um for the need for legislation to move
forward on an agreement or something
like that then that would likely be
included in in a report that's issued to
the to the oh my God the legislature I'm
sorry
um uh yeah so I imagine that in there I
think you know in these reports
legislative recommendations would be
made but I think they'd likely be made
only when there's a consensus among the
group
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um Mr Casper I think you said that uh it
takes time to get a license to join
engines and I think you said something
about three months yeah uh can can you
elaborate on that a little bit please
well because I'm not a utility and I uh
submitted to have a license to use the
software so that we could look in the
database and get a better handle on the
numbers of double polls uh I submitted
my application to uh engines and one of
the requirements is they have to reach
out to all the utilities within
the state of New Hampshire that a pot of
engines and get an agreement from them
that that would be okay with them
that uh
so I'm sure it'll come
eventually but
um
it would be make it easier for for my
department uh as we move if we move
forward with this committee uh to commit
the resources that we have myself and my
electrical inspector to work with the
utilities to find a solution follow up
follow up
so who who controls engines who who is
it that's saying you know you're not
you're not good enough because you're
not utility at your government
I I guess
um it's because it's it's a joint
um
company that created engines for all the
utilities to be a part of that it was
strictly designed and paid for by
utilities
representative partial has a question
thank you chair and thank you for being
here today uh you mentioned earlier
Washington State and I might be
incorrecting the terminology One Touch
make ready
now are other states considering that as
a solution are you aware of that as well
well I
just probably said in our conversations
every a lot of the other states similar
situation that we're in they all thought
that boy that's unique maybe you know
they we're all going to start to look
into doing that in and again as you can
tell this the the process does take a
little bit and everybody's in we're all
in the same boat moving these things
forward and so I I know my counterpart
in Pennsylvania yes I I talked to him
more often than anybody and they're
pushing it in a similar way as we did
representative Harrington follow-up
sorry thank you so much chair
um my constituents are really crying and
then and that's what I'm hearing this
from my constituents um and I'm looking
at the uh deadline for a report being
November 1st I know that the utilities
are very good about getting out there
once I identify a problem
for the most part
um is there any way I could ally some of
the concerns of my constituents by
letting them know that
while this is looking to be an ongoing
without a sunset Clause
um
committee at the end of it all they will
get results
that is certainly the goal um but
obviously nobody can predict the future
you know I can't predict who shows up to
these meetings or not but that is
certainly the intent
um regarding I guess a Sunset date or
anything like that I don't think the
department felt a Sunset date was needed
because
um in the language of this bill the
stakeholder groups are called at the
discretion of Paul over here so if there
is say an agreement to move forward with
say legislation or maybe there's a
non-legislative fix
um you know we can have that agreement
and if need be we can come in later on
and say we don't need the stakeholder
group anymore in statute we can take it
away but I think we want to have that
flexibility discretion to call these
meetings because as Paul mentioned this
is something we'll that will likely take
quite a bit of time
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question uh let me just say ditto
what my colleague just said I made the
mistake of taking my wife to the dump
the other day not to drop her off but
she just was in the car with me and we
happened to drive by the pole that's
been hanging there for about a month and
she said why don't you do something
about that so anyways uh a couple of
questions uh first one would be
says that the stakeholders group shall
consist of then it lists a whole mess of
people it doesn't list anyone from doe
but it does say the director of the
division of enforcement will be it'll be
under them is it necessary to list them
as a member as well just so we don't
have a well you know that's a grift
question I guess uh thank you um I don't
necessarily think that's required I
imagine because these meetings are
called at the discretion of Paul over
here I don't imagine he'll just say
everybody come to the department meet in
this room and he's just going to be up
in his office
um he'll I'm sure he'll be actively
involved for sure
um and just to reiterate I know there's
some question on the membership of this
stakeholder group it largely emulates
the uh commission makeup from the study
commission that met uh last year thank
you follow up follow up yeah uh you
mentioned this is a multi-state issue
and I think it's a national issue
everybody I've talked to over the last
15 years when you bring up the subject
over they just go ah we have no solution
have you pursued going through some
organization like Nesco because some of
these utilities are obviously in
Massachusetts New Hampshire and
Connecticut and maybe coming up with a
regional approach uh through an
organization such as well either Nesco
or neck puck or something like that
that
that's a good question is it that's a
good possibility especially we're
working through uh eversource where
they're in three states
um
I I I guess
just to start this process just to get
you know to kick start it and get a feel
or just to get a better idea where
everybody is coming from
kind of collectively ask or get them for
each individual group say what do you
see the issue being
okay I just yeah I'm assuming that the
the eversource is going to have the same
issues in Connecticut all states are
working on this sir okay uh
representative thank you it's it's just
how it's not an easy thing to solve it's
not and uh
hopefully we can
create a collaborative environment to
get it done
okay great thank you very much
representative Noel has another question
thank you Mr chair
thinking of it the the the problem from
the utilities point of view is there a
scarcity issue in in getting the
attachments and having the polls
available uh ready and uh able to be put
in uh in time is that is that part of
the issue
I I it is positive issue not so much in
the supply chain side I don't believe
but in in uh the employ employee
resource resources it say on to go out
and transfer on a set a new poll and
transfer everything that's probably
could be anywhere from an 8 to 12 hour
14 day start to finish so just quite a
bit of work involved with that
um I I think it's just each
and again
the transfer of the next one Downs
relatively simple
it's you're on the next wire down from
the electric you're just transferring
excuse me your wire from the old damage
poll to the new one make the attachment
you're done
in the next one comes along and usually
what happens is the next one down when
they after they've attacked they cut the
pole take that section off so the next
one down can now easily attach
okay representative Reynolds has a
question
it's less of a question Mr chairman than
a comment I guess I
okay if it's a comment could you reserve
that to the executive session
public hearings are for obtaining
information from the public yeah so we
want to restrict our activity here this
morning let me ask you a question let me
make it a question then I I guess
make it a quick one please
is it I'm frustrated to hear you say
it's not an easy problem to solve in
since you seem to have
given us an example where a state and
maybe a couple of States seem to have
found the solution
um is it really that hard to solve if if
the if the issue is the delay
and the cost obviously
of having each individual Telecom
provider mobilize their own crew their
own truck you know their own police
detail to put cones around the truck in
the street to work on that pole if if
the solution is to have a contractor
all the utility all the Telecom or all
the utilities uh come up and fund a
single contractor to make the transfers
all at once a much more
resource efficient solution is it really
that hard
is it hot excuse me it's hot no sir it's
not it's getting everybody to agree to
that that could be the difficulty
there's the hard part that's the rub
thank you
okay seeing no more questions I want to
thank the department of energy for being
here to discuss
Senate Bill 16 with us and having no
more pink cards on this bill I would
like to close the public hearing or on
Senate bill 16.
we will now move on and open a public
hearing on Senate Bill 40 relative to
participation in net energy metering by
small hydroelectric generators and I
will call first on Senator David Waters
the prime sponsor of the bill
well actually Senator abart I guess is
the prime sponsor so Senator Waters is
filling in this morning for Senator
abard so Senator it's all yours
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee on behalf of Senator avard I'm
introducing
Senate bill
um 40. uh this bill addresses a very
particular situation
um related to Brookline monac paper
mills and
um when we passed 315 and moved the net
metering up to five megawatts this issue
came to the fore because of the way in
which the interconnection point is done
for these two uh paper mills I think
you'll see from the bipartisan
on nature of the support for this bill
and uh the testimony that we heard in
the Senate that this is a problem that
we kind of thought we had fixed
previously but we realized we need to
change some of the language a little bit
to make sure that these paper mills can
under the provisions of net metering and
the kind of metering that they they do
for their power production and the use
on site that we can make this work for
them so much of what you see in the bill
and I know that Heidi Kroll is here to
address some of the details
um and uh but much of the detail that's
in the bill
gets that language right and part of it
is to make sure that this bill is just
for this situation
I know we're in New Hampshire but not
every bill is a slippery slope it's not
a ski area Okay so IT addresses this
particular issue by making a couple of
tweaks to it and the we were very
careful because the concerns raised by
the department of energy about well then
every other companies want to come in
and do this say well they'd have to get
us to pass a bill this bill is only for
this it's does no slippery soap doesn't
open other doors so what the bill does
do is to clarify a couple of things it
says that
um you know each of these two
hydroelectric dams the amount of power
they generate they will be able to
determine what they use on site and then
what it's going to be potentially
exported
and they will be responsible for
um the metering there and making reports
intervene you have a transparent process
and reports
um in audits so that it is clear that
the metering has been done uh in the
appropriate appropriate way I know that
you have because of a very recent
agreement that has been reached between
Brookline and White Mountain paper that
the chair has an amendment which just
tweaks the language a little bit more
which I'm sure you will be discussing
will be discussed by
um Heidi Kroll when she comes up to to
speak before you
um so the technicalities are there I
will probably leave most of that to
um Heidi Kroll's and and others to
answer but I think the big picture here
is that you know we are committed to
these hydroelectric generators and to
the paper manufacturing these are
important part of New Hampshire economy
jobs and so on
um I think also the basic principles
under house bill 315 where we said that
power produced in New Hampshire is good
for New Hampshire
um and it it helps us in a lot of ways
to keep our potentially our costs down
so this is one small piece in that and
that and quite necessary for these two
um for these paper mills and
hydroelectric generation to be able to
succeed under net metering thank you Mr
chairman
thank you senator for introducing this
bill on behalf of senator avard
I know that as a member of Senate energy
and natural resources you have been
involved excuse me been involved in the
uh
deliberations on the bill and the many
changes that have been made to it over
the course of the last six or eight
months or whatever
but I have a kind of a overarching
fundamental question and that is that
our constitution our state constitution
says that we don't make laws that
provide preferential treatment for any
in person or group of persons so why is
it justifiable to pass legislation like
this which seems to be preferential to a
small group of persons
well thanks for your question and um
my take on this not being a
constitutional lawyer
is that we are not being preferential
what we are doing is clarifying that the
policy that we have passed in this
legislature can in fact apply as it
appropriately should to entities that
might take advantage of it and so I see
this as a technical issue not a
preferential one
great thank you very much
questions from the committee
representative Harrington has a question
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question
um why the was energy storage facilities
added I'm not quite sure what that I
mean enlighten me I just don't know what
it why it's there thanks for your
question I should have mentioned that in
my introduction
um
energy storage is becoming increasingly
important component of how people
operate their energy production because
it allows you to take excess capacity
use it on site later or use that as a
way of exporting power into the grid
when it's needed so you can avoid Peak
uh demand charges and help out the
overall system by being able to put
energy back in and then filling up your
batteries when um uh you know when when
the power is cheaper and so for for
these kinds of circumstances we are I
think we're seeing that it seems
appropriate under
the statutes that we have passed the way
in which we Define energy storage
systems that we want to make sure that
they are appropriately seen as part of a
capacity here not as a separate kind of
entity so that's why it's in there
follow up follow up so uh just so I'm
clear on this they let's say we're going
to use batteries for example they the
this uh the people that qualify under
this provision could store as much of
electricity as they could possibly get
into batteries but they could only
output at the same level is that they
were allowed to generate so there'd be a
cap on the output and mega in you know
kilowatt hours for example
yes thank you um I think you're
absolutely right representative
um about the way you that you're you're
defining it that we're including it up
here but the governing language over the
net metering
it is contained within that so it's not
a separate kind of entity the overall
question is however whether it's coming
right off the right off the dam or if
it's coming from the storage that we've
put some of your power that the same
this this you're still under under the
same requirements of the five megawatts
thank you
other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you Senator Waters
appreciate you being here Oops I did see
representative Bernardi's hand but if
it's getting any more technical I think
it's got to go to the Hardy crawl okay
all right Senator uh representative
Bernardi okay thank you very much okay
he defers all right so next up is uh
Griffin Roberge from the Department of
energy
thank you chairman vostner before you
start uh Mr Ropers just I would like to
remind members of the committee if you
have electronic devices please mute them
so that we don't
constantly be barraged with dings and
other noises thank you Mr robersh thank
you uh for the record Griffin Roberge
State energy program manager at the
department of energy uh here to testify
in opposition to Senate Bill 40 as
amended by the Senate
um for background this statute permits a
hydroelectric generator with a total
Peak capacity at or below one megawatt
that began operation before July 1 of 21
and shares equipment or facilities with
other generators or electric utility
customers for interconnection shall be
able to participate in net energy
metering even if the aggregate capacity
of those generators exceeds the one
megawatt cap
for background because I think it's
important is this statute was created in
2021 through Senate Bill 91 to address
the specific circumstance at Monadnock
paper mills I'm sure folks who are
around during that time remember all the
various parts of that beautiful bill
um that that Mill owns and operates
three small hydroelectric facilities
behind the meter at the Mill site and
all of those dams share the single
interconnection point collectively those
three dams constitute about 1.9
megawatts of capacity but due to net
metering laws and rules at the time
those three dams were considered a
single 1.9 megawatt facility and were
unable to net meter their excess
generation
Senate Bill 91 created in statute you
largely see on lines three to twelve
um uh created the statute to remedy this
unique issue to allow Monadnock paper
mills to participate in net metering as
customer generators based on their
individual total Peak generating
capacity and not be restricted from
doing so because they just shared a
single interconnection point what Senate
Bill 40 seeks to do is it amends that
statute further to permit those types of
facilities to be as outlined
specifically on lines 12 to 15. eligible
as a customer generator as a matter of
law without regard to whether such
hydroelectric generator is the electric
utility customer account of record at
the point of interconnection to the
electric grid the department is strongly
opposed to this language and strongly
wants to convey to policy makers that
this is a significant policy decision
that lies before them the remainder of
this bill from LA lines 15 on spell out
a process by which the hydroelectric
generator would submit information to
the department regarding the facility's
proposed methodology for reading and
document documenting that meter data the
department has really no position on any
of that we'd be fine with with that
language it is quite technical but our
concern lies on lines 12 to 15.
because it under it fundamentally
undermines the current statute by
allowing a hydroelectric generator a
generator not a customer itself to be
considered a customer generator
regardless of whether that generator is
the utility customer point of
interconnection in short the bill seeks
to remove customer from customer
generator and allows a generator located
behind the meter and not a utility
customer itself to derive the benefits
of net metering in New Hampshire the
Genesis of this bill as well as House
Bill 458 which this committee retained
stems from several hydroelectric
facilities owned by Brookfield Renewable
that are located behind the meter at
White Mountain paper in Gorham New
Hampshire on paper White Mountain paper
is the utility customer and serves as
the interconnection point for all of
these hydroelectric dams are located
behind the meter how Brookfield sells
power from its hydroelectric assets is
outlined an existing power purchase
agreement between both of those private
parties while some may argue that Senate
Bill 40 only affects this one
Arrangement between Brookfield and White
Mountain paper the department cannot
authoritatively confirm that the
department does not maintain the
database or a master list of all the
metering Arrangements in the state there
may very well be potentially we cannot
confirm this other hydroelectric
facilities and private entities that
this bill in this language would impact
and again policymakers should be aware
that this is an important policy
consideration net metering in essence
allows for excess generation at the
customer level to be added to the grid
the fundamental issue that this language
aligns 12 to 15 presents is it
establishes a precedent for
hydroelectric generators to try to amend
State Statute to slowly chip away at the
definition of what a customer generator
truly is
we do continue to contend that any
characterization that this bill or the
bill that was entertained earlier House
Bill 458 is a technical fix or a minor
change or a cleanup is inaccurate there
is nothing in the record from Senate
Bill 491 in either the house or the
Senate to indicate that that bill in
this statute was meant to cover any
Arrangement between Brookfield and White
Mountain paper it does not incentivize
any new generation or directly lower
electric rates again it's a significant
policy change that this committee should
carefully consider
enacting this change creates a precedent
for certain facilities to capitalize on
the benefits of net metering and opens
the door for future legislative attempts
to slowly chip away at the definition of
customer generator and I do want to
emphasize that while A legislature
cannot bind a future legislature by
continually cracking opening that door
if you do it for one you could
potentially make an argument that others
could come forward and do the same that
is the argument that the department is
presenting to you here today again the
department believes that this bill stems
from an existing power purchase
agreement that was again arrived at
between two private parties White
Mountain paper and Brookfield Renewable
it's our understanding that that there
have been some discussions that there's
potentially an amendment that's been
reached by both parties that amendment
was shared with the Department I believe
Saturday or Sunday this weekend
our department is reviewing that
language and doesn't take a position on
anything like that but I'm just
commenting on the bill which is here the
department does believe that there may
potentially be a non-legislative fix
that could address this issue in the
existing power purchase agreement and
with that I'm happy to conclude my
testimony and take any questions
thank you very much representative
Bernardi has a question for you
thank you Mr chairman so uh I believe
you answered the question that I was
going to ask but uh that is are there
are you aware of any other Hydro
facility situations which
uh this bill could apply to beyond the
Brookfield uh one and I think you said
there's possibility that there are more
but you just don't know we just don't
know that's correct thank you
further questions for Mr Roberge
representative Nutter has one thank you
Mr chairman when you testified in the
Senate what was their reasoning for
leading in this language on lines 12 to
15. uh I I I can't speak for that just
because a counterpart of mine Josh
Elliott testifies uh before the Senate
but our concern was much the same over
there I think
um in the broadest Strokes off the top
of my head I do not believe the Senate
found the language overly problematic
additional questions representative
McGee has one
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
robesch for taking my question
um you mentioned changes to the power
purchase agreement but I thought this
bill was to try and correct the
additional energy that would be eligible
for net metering which would be really
just
um adding these small Hydro facilities
to SB 91 I I think the reason that it's
um that it's got so much bipartisan
support on both sides of the wall is
probably because most of us are
acknowledging that there was an intent
there that these guys would be included
in the first place sure and thank you
for the question
um you know I look through I I was in
the Senate when Senate Bill 91 went
through I spent some time going through
the record for both of those bills I
think anybody who was around during that
time remembered that the reasoning
behind this language was for a specific
Arrangement at Monadnock paper mills to
address that specific instance now this
bill comes forward and seeks to say well
there's another one that wasn't covered
um the department contends that you know
this is a policy decision that folks are
making you are slowly opening the door
to weather down the actual definition of
customer generate it's a different thing
between Monadnock paper and this one
where in the monadnaught instance all
three of those hydroelectric facilities
were owned by monadnaught paper mills
this is entirely different we have
Brookfield Renewable owning the
facilities and then White Mountain paper
serving as the interconnection point for
those facilities so whereas before
ownership was linear across the board in
this instance it isn't
um we do have again significant concern
with the with the language on on lines
12 to 15 that indicate that
hydroelectric facilities such as those
in that instance are now a customer
generators regardless of whether or not
they are the electric utility customer
on the account of record
um it just it Waters down effectively
the definition of customer generator why
do we think it carries significant
consideration for policy makers to
consider
follow-up yes thank you Mr chairman
um I just I'm still laughing at Waters
down I thought that was cute
um
so
you know I think I I think I lost my
follow-up okay representative munz has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for coming in today
um uh I know I'm I'm I know I'm four
months into my education on this on
these topics but uh still a lot to learn
so bear with me
um what is the what is the economic loss
that I assume Brookfield
believes they are suffering that is that
we're trying to remedy thank you for the
question I I would respectfully suggest
you maybe asking that question the
Brookfield when they come up to testify
okay thank you thank you
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr thanks to thank you for
taking my question just for
clarification uh
um I agree with what you're assessing
there so but could you explain what is
the what will be the overall effect of
your perception of this policy change
going forward in the future thank you so
I think the Department's position is
that it creates
in our and in our opinion the dangerous
precedent is that the legislature if
enacting this bill effectively allows a
generator not a customer itself but an
actual generator to derive the benefits
of net energy metering
um
it opens the door and again a current
legislature cannot bind to Future
legislature anybody can bring forward a
bill any on any issue that they want
um
it opens the door for other folks other
generators to make the case before
legislatures legislators in the future
that hey you know
we'd like we'd like you to do this
because you did it for you did it in
these instances in the past why not do
it for this and again in our opinion it
starts to slowly open the door for
watering down the uh provisions of
customer generator thank you
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Roberts yeah so I'm I'm still trying to
wrap my head around what is the real
problem about
changing what their customer generator
is what what what are the implications
that that that it's such a big problem
sure so thank you for the question so
again net metering in the state allows
for excess generation again at the
customer level to be added to the grid
that Excess power that you put back on
the grid so solar on one's house that
type of thing that they own this is
entirely different this is these are not
insignificant hydroelectric assets these
are in you know well over I think 10
megawatts and I think Brookfield can
certainly provide
um further information on that but
these hydroelectric resources are not
interconnected to the grids themselves
they can certainly undertake that
process but I imagine they don't that
that would be very cost prohibitive for
them to do so what they want to do from
what is online's 12 to 15 is that they
are not the customer they are not the
customer of record White Mountain paper
is they want to in our view
um circum you know walk around that with
language on on lines 12 to 15. they
are now a customer generator as a matter
of law with no regard as to whether or
not they are interconnected to the grid
themselves or they are the utility
customer themselves again you are in in
in essence allowing a generator itself
to derive the benefits of net energy
metering in the state
so did I just understand you to say that
the facilities that are addressed in
this bill namely the Brookfield uh owned
hydroelectric facilities are much larger
than the Monadnock paper mill facilities
that were addressed by the earlier
legislation that's the Department's
understanding
representative Reynolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Roberts for being here um at the end of
your
just at the end of your introductory
remarks I thought I thought I heard you
say
that you believe there might be a
non-legislative solution to this
situation are you willing to share that
um
that
Prospect with us at this time or would
that be
um do you think that would be sort of
premature no that's that's fine I
appreciate the question so again a power
purchase agreement you know at least
this this one was a rank arranged at by
private parties White Mountain paper and
Brookfield Renewable I understand that
discussions have been going and I
believe that there's an amendment coming
around but you know the Department's not
in the position to find a remedy to a
power purchase agreement between two
parties it's just you know we think that
there may potentially be one through
that route and private those two private
parties should explore that route
okay representative McGee has another
question yes thank you
um so my question is around the build
out of hydro in the state because when I
first joined the committee we had
testimony that the hydro in the state
was pretty much built out so I just
wanted to say that here in the hearing
and also I wondered if you would comment
on whether you think Hydro is in a
you know a different category in terms
of Renewables because it provides steady
state energy and you know it can be
deployed when needed so it's kind of
been a kind of in a different category
in terms of whether we're going to want
to optimize it and and make it
economically feasible for us to be using
that energy
sure so thank you for the question so I
would certainly agree that Hydro
electric power is certainly renewable
um you know it certainly has you know
higher capacity factors compared to
other types of renewable energy sources
whether or not you know policy makers
feel the need to further incentivize a
hydroelectric generation in the state or
you know make policy changes for them
that's obviously decisions for this
committee to make but obviously as
Department of energy we certainly want
to provide our input as is directed
obviously the legislatures under statute
thank you okay
okay seeing no further questions from
the committee we want to thank you for
your testimony thank you Robert and I'll
call next on Heidi Kroll
who is representing Brookfield Renewable
and manadnock paper mills and needs
about seven or eight minutes to discuss
uh
the bill and maybe some potential
changes to it
Ms Grove welcome good morning Mr
chairman and members of the committee
for the record my name is Heidi Kroll I
work at Gallagher Callahan and gartrell
and I'm here today representing a
Brookfield Renewable as well as
Monadnock paper mills which is a family
owned
paper mill in Bennington New Hampshire
it happens to be the oldest continuously
operating Mill in the United States uh
dating back to 1819.
um
so sb40 so I appreciate the opportunity
to testify here before you this morning
um sb40 amends existing law as you've
heard it's RSA 362 a 9 Roman 20 and it
provides additional Clarity so that the
law can actually be implemented this law
was passed in 2021 with bipartisan
support as part of SB 91
um you may recall that SB 91 and House
Bill 315 which was the municipal group
net metering Bill we're signed into law
by the governor at a signing ceremony in
August of 2021 and I know that the
chairman and vice chairman who were
there in attendance
um so the the hydro provision in SB 91
was intended to essentially level the
playing field for Monadnock paper mills
and Brookfield and I know Steve is ready
from Brookfield who's with me today can
speak to the testimony that they did
give in support of SB 91 both I believe
there's oral testimonies as well as
written testimony
um
so so the provision in SB 91 was
intended to level the playing field for
Monadnock paper mills and Brookfield so
that their Hydro facilities those that
are under five megawatts are allowed to
participate in net metering just like
any other New Hampshire Hydro facility
is already allowed to when they're under
five megawatts so in passing SB 91 the
legislature recognized that these are
local run of river base load Hydro
facilities that are important to
reliability among other things and the
legislature also recognized that these
hydros meet the eligibility requirements
for net metering but for the fact that
they have Legacy wiring issues that
require additional statutory guidance
and the legislature recognized that it
would really be unfair to exclude these
two hydrocytes simply because of this
Legacy wiring so what is the Legacy
wiring issue at each site both at
Monadnock paper mills and at the
Brookfield site there are mult multiple
Hydro facilities that share a single
interconnection point with the grid
namely through the on-site paper mills
today no new renewable facilities would
be wired to the Grid in this way but
that's just how it was done when these
Hydro facilities were first built to
power these Mills many many decades ago
and the analogy I would give you is that
the wiring that you find in an antique
home would not be how you would wire a
house if you were building it today
so despite passage of SB 91 around 20
months ago to date neither Monadnock
paper mills nor Brookfield have been
able to actually use the law to knit
meter the language in sb40 is needed so
that the law can actually work
sb40 will ensure a couple of key things
first of all that only monadnox and
brookfield's Hydra facilities that are
under five megawatts will be allowed to
participate in net metering that any
other on-site generation or energy
storage will not be able to participate
and it finally makes clear that it's
we're only talking about the excess
generation from the eligible facilities
after the on-site Mills power needs are
met only that excess will will be
eligible to participate
um so again with respect to the excess
you may be aware that
um municipalities schools counties and
the state have had a lot of interest in
group net metering with small New
Hampshire Hydro beginning years ago when
Hydro facilities of one megawatt or less
were allowed to net meter and continuing
with the passage of House Bill 315 and
the municipal group net metering program
where political subdivisions and the
state can group net meter with
facilities up to five megawatts
my understanding is that there's
currently actually not enough small
Hydro available to meet the demand
in the municipal group net metering
program the demand from the various
political entities in the state for
hydro so sb40 will make a small but I
think meaningful amount of additional
base load hydropower available to the
municipal group net metering program and
for those municipalities counties and
the state entities that are waiting for
more supply of hydro this modest Edition
I think would be welcome to them
so as I mentioned um you know that
neither Monadnock paper mills or
Brickfield have been able to net meter
under the current law and the reason
that is after the passage of SB 91 when
both entities reached out to eversource
to start the process to participate in
net metering two issues were raised as
needing additional guidance from the
legislature and that guidance is found
in sb40 so the first issue is that on
both the Monadnock site and the
Brookfield site there are generators
that are eligible for net metering there
are also a few generators that are not
eligible for net metering and so the
issue is that we need a methodology to
separate out what is the eligible excess
generation from the ineligible excess
generation to determine how much is
allowed to go into the net metering
program
so a few details on that in the case of
Monadnock paper mills they have a steam
generator a steam turbine on-site that
runs off of waste heat from the mill
when the mill is running that steam
turbine runs as well and they use all of
their hydroelectric power as well to run
their Mill and in addition they bought
that meets about 50 percent of their
needs and they buy the other 50 percent
from the competitive market
um in the case of monadnoc they would be
net metering their excess
hydrogeneration when they're not running
evenings weekends holidays the steam
turbine would not be running obviously
the if the Mill's not running there's no
steam um no waste heat but nonetheless
um eversource was looking for
um
just assurances kind of belts and
suspenders to make sure that there's a
methodology to absolutely demonstrate
that there is any excess generation
that's going out onto the grid is only
coming from the eligible facilities and
not from the steam turbine
in the case of Brookfield there are four
hydros on site that are under five
megawatts and so eligible for the
municipal group net metering program
and there are also two hydros there that
are slightly above five megawatts those
are not eligible
and so a portion of the output from the
Brookfield Hydro facilities is used to
serve White Mountain paper under a
long-term purchase power agreement as
you heard discussion of that earlier
um so what sb40 requires of both
Monadnock paper mills and Brookfield
would be to follow a methodology that
will be approved and regularly audited
by both the department of energy and
eversource where
um Monada paper mills in Brookfield are
responsible for reading the meters of
all of the on-site generators
documenting how much each generator is
producing in each hour how much power is
being used to serve the Mills on-site
load how much excess generation is going
on to the grid and then of that how much
of that excess is eligible for net
metering so sb40 lays all of this out
and the language does reflect input that
we got from both the department of
energy and eversource
to to make sure that that process is
very clear
the second issue that sb40 addresses is
unique to Brookfield at the site behind
the point of interconnection that is
shared
the interconnection point with the grid
the hydros are owned by Brookfield and
they share the interconnection point
with the mill which is owned by White
Mountain paper
and as you heard White Mountain paper is
currently the customer of record at that
shared point of interconnection with the
hydro facilities
um
the current law actually does have some
language about the hydroelectric
generator meeting other various
requirements and it talks about that
shares equipment or facilities with
other generators or electric utility
customers for interconnection to the
grid shall be eligible to participate in
net energy mirroring as a customer
generator so the language is there sb40
simply adds some clarification
to make sure that you know everybody's
comfortable with what's being made
explicit
and really this is necessary because the
only alternative would be very costly
and frankly cost prohibitive uh
infrastructure upgrades that would you
know I think frankly run counter to the
intent and purpose of SB 91 that was
recognized
so as you may recall from the hearing on
House Bill 458 which was the sister Bill
to sb40 White Mountain paper asked for
some more time to review sb40 to ensure
that there would not be any impact on
their PPA with Brookfield and I'm happy
to report that on Brookfield and White
Mountain paper have worked very
collaboratively over the last month or
so and have reached an agreement on a
few changes to the bill and I do have
copies with that that I can circulate
around to the committee as well as an
agreement that's set forth in a sidebar
letter and you know Brookfield has said
all along in its past testimony on you
know prior iterations of this bill as as
well as the testimony on sb40 in the
Senate has said all along that what
they're looking for is the opportunity
to net meter any excess generation from
its Hydro facilities after serving White
Mountain papers power needs and the
proposed amendment and the sidebar let
her clarify that commitment
um
finally as you know as you've heard
earlier doe has raised some concerns
about the customer generator part of the
bill as being a change that could
potentially be precedent setting and
from our perspective there are several
reasons why we don't think that this
should be a concern
um during Doe's testimony in the Senate
on sb40 they did acknowledge that the
bill is very narrowly written and you
heard that from Senator Waters and and
we would agree with that they
acknowledged that it would only apply to
the situation that we're we've been
talking about here today and not apply
to any other party without
explicit approval by the legislature and
passage of a future law and the final
thing I would say is and I've said this
once before but um no new renewable
facility is going to interconnect to the
grid using this type of Legacy wiring
design that you see on these Old Mill
sites so we don't see any concerns with
this bill being precedent setting
So In Sum and then I'll turn it over to
Steve to add his um
editions
um you know sb40 is very narrow in scope
and application it does only apply to
two run of river base load Hydro sites
due to their unique Legacy wiring
situation it does not and cannot apply
to any solar projects it does not and
cannot apply to any facilities that
became operational after July 1st of
2021 and it does ensure that the power
needs of the on-site paper mills will be
met before any excess base load Hydro
power is net metered so I'll turn it
over to Steve and then we'd be happy to
answer any questions
exciting uh good morning Steve's already
with Brookfield excuse me Brookfield
Renewable uh I think Heidi outlined uh
the history and the situation well
um I want to First acknowledge that as
she described we've had very productive
conversations with white mountain paper
uh since uh the sister bill was heard in
the house in early February I do
appreciate the efforts and the time of
White Mountain paper and its
Representatives including Mr Cousy who
is here today the result of those
conversations is an amendment that you
will see I think in advance of the
executive session on this bill and that
really clarifies explicitly what was
always implied in our effort here which
is to treat only what is not being
utilized by the mill as eligible for the
facility and there was some suggestion
that these are very large facilities or
that might be a lot of Supply
the the focus here is on facilities
under five megawatts and the reality is
given the the mill load what we're
talking about in the form of Supply that
would be eligible under any uh future
approved methodology by the doe would
likely to be something on the order of
two less than five megawatt projects so
while there's four that are under five
megawatts these projects are serving the
mill so we are just talking about the
the excess here I just want to clarify
that we did in our conversations with
white mountain paper try to address
Doe's stated proposal for
kind of getting around this issue
without legislation
neither party in Brookfield and I think
I can say the same for White Mountain
paper was interested in engaging in that
dialogue as it would require amendments
to the existing PPA in either side wants
to open that up for conversation so I do
just want to make that clear uh while we
are not a retail customer of the utility
given the site configuration we are an
interconnection customer of eversource
we do have an existing relationship with
the utility
um I also just want to note that
um there was some suggestion that
Brookfield maybe wasn't considered or
wasn't involved in in the initial
conversations a couple years ago I did
submit written testimony there is
YouTube testimony it was a zoom at the
time of a house version of of this
policy proposal that I did testify on
and we worked closely with Monadnock
paper at the time on the language that
was drafted it was anticipated given
support for it that our issues were to
be dealt with through that language it
was not until we engaged directly with
the utility and and with doe that we
realized there were some additive
clarifying concerns here so I'm happy to
answer any questions but um appreciate
everyone's time on this
okay thank you before I open it up to
the full committee I would like to ask a
couple of questions myself
the first question is
what happens if White Mountain paper
shuts down
and should we add language to this
legislation
that addresses that issue
uh well that that's a future uh concern
that I hope we don't have to deal with
um in that case uh I think it would be
no different than any other Hydro
facility that participates in the
program
um whereby the facilities under five
megawatts would would qualify
theoretically if there's no longer a
customer there
um then Brookfield would become the uh
the retail customer at the point of
interconnection but that's a future
scenario that you know has some some
hair around it for sure
thank you my follow-up question would be
would it be
advisable or desirable to remove lines
13 14 and 15 from this legislation
so I think that gets to the to the
harder the matter that we're trying to
to solve for and that we weren't able to
through uh private conversation as as I
indicated and that's just the reality of
the site configuration and Brookfield
not having a path to being the utilities
retail customer absent infrastructure
changes that would be cost prohibitive
so you think it is essential that the
definition of customer generator be
altered to
move this legislation or move this
process forward
it is I mean there's there's language as
I mentioned in my testimony if you look
further up
um the original SB 91 language if you
will where it talks about a
hydroelectric generator and has a
variety of conditions and it goes on to
say that shares equipment or facilities
with other generators we're adding in
energy storage facilities there are no
energy for storage facilities currently
at the Brookfield or Monadnock site but
in the future there could be we're
talking about what's being
interconnected so that shares equipment
or facilities with other generators
energy storage facilities or electric
utility customers so it says say
electric utility customers for
interconnection to the grid shall be
eligible to participate in net energy
metering as a customer generator so that
language was already there in the
original bill but the the feeling was
that it needed clarification so the
lines that you refer to Mr chairman
provide that clarification
all right thank you representative
Thomas has a question thank you Mr chair
that's
very close to the question I was going
to ask but I'm going to ask it
differently
would you be amenable
in your amendment to work with doe on
lines 12 through 15 to reword them in a
manner that would allay their fears on
on what they expressed because that
appears to be a major concern to them
the rest of the bill is fine so a
rewording that might further explain
what it won't include in the future
maybe or something of that nature would
you be willing to do that in your
Amendment sure I mean we're always happy
to try to work with the interested
parties and we have um you know worked
with doe on on this bill
um over the uh the time that it's been
in development
um I think really the issue is that
um it's a difference of opinion about
whether this is precedent setting or not
and I did mention that in in my
testimony where um uh you know they did
even in the Senate when sb40 was being
heard they did acknowledge that this is
a very narrowly written Bill we've done
that intentionally
um to to try to allay the fears
um or the concerns they acknowledge that
it would only apply to the situation
that we've been talking about and you
know here today and that um you know
anything in the future would require
legislative approval and passage of a
law and as I mentioned too
um you know
this is the whole Crux of all of this is
that we have just these Legacy wiring
situations at these two Old Mill sites
no one in today's world if they were
building something a new renewable
facility would ever dream I think to to
wire
um you know Connect into the grid using
this type of approach
um so you know we're happy to continue
to work with doe but um I think it might
just be a a difference of opinion about
why do you think it's precedent setting
or not
follow up uh thank you
I agree it could be a difference of
opinion but perhaps
would you still like to look at some
wording that might you know maybe a few
more words to allay the difference of
opinions so both sides agree that we
have no difference of opinion we're
happy to do that yes thank you
representative partial has a question
thank you chair and thanks for being
here today
um you mentioned Legacy wiring a couple
times and my question is
if you were able if we were
economically feasible to replace that
Legacy wiring would that go any distance
in solving the problem to begin with
um I think I'll let Steve answer that
question
yeah the reality is is that the the
reason there is no path to to work
around this configuration is the fact
that doing so would require investment
that would not make economic sense for
for the site
no follow-up thanks
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you both for
coming here
um two two-part question
um I I'm I'm assuming that white
mountain
would qualify as a as a custom generator
or a customer generator and would be
able to get the benefit of net metering
if that's the case why why why can't you
and White Mountain work out or amend
your power purchase agreement or create
some other agreement that essentially
has them collecting the benefit and then
transferring that to you why do we need
to go through this elaborate process of
amending legislation yeah thanks for the
question actually that's what we we did
discuss that in our
interactions with white mountain paper
as that was a recommendation from the
doe as I indicated you know addressing
changes to the existing agreements is
not something that either side feels
comfortable with and and certainly
adding some administrative complexity
for the mill is not something that that
we're seeking to to implement so it's
just a lot more streamlined for
Brookfield the dam owners to be able to
interact with the utility for
participation
and I might just add if I could
as part of the the methodology and the
auditing that's been proposed that's
also something that Brookfield uh would
would take on itself so we would work
with the doe and with the utility but
all of the administrative complexities
and whatnot would be managed by uh
follow-up follow-up
on that last Point
um
you you said you're going to be willing
to take all that on yet on um page two
of the amendment in lines
eight through ten through nine it says
that the cost of recovering those the
the that the recovery of those
incremental uh manual billing process
will be passed on to utility customers
so so that was language requested by
eversource
um so we're not certain you know the
scope of what that would entail but we
expect it would be very limited given
the fact that my question is why why
wouldn't you be willing to assume those
costs yourself so and not have it be
passed on to utility customers that's a
conversation
um
So currently this is already happening
with all of the other net metering
Arrangements that the utilities are
doing this sort of um
manual billing process and so
um
becoming a participant in net metering
we are just joining a group of all you
know otherwise already eligible
facilities that are that are net
metering so this is just current
protocol already and so uh eversource
just wanted this acknowledged in in here
but it's it's what they're already doing
for all of the other
um uh anybody else who's net metering as
well so this is status quo basically
since you've asked two questions I'm
going to move on to representative
Corman
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so am I understanding this
correctly then that because
Brookfield and White Mountain paper
could not
come to an agreement on how to change
the PPA you're asking for a legislative
solution
so what we're looking for is
implementing what we thought was the
initial intent of the legislation we've
we have an existing agreement with white
mountain paper uh that dates back to
2021 uh neither side wishes to amend
that in any way for a variety of reasons
uh including the the pricing which uh
was established in a in a different
Market I think that is is favorable for
for the mill so it's not something that
that we feel like we want to engage on
and I think they would say the same uh
and uh and really it's just a matter of
trying to implement the initial
legislation that we thought achieved
this
and just to be clear on that I mean um
you know White Mountain paper is in the
business in the paper business and so
they're
um they're not really interested in
trying to engage
and being a customer generator and kind
of taking on as Steve was saying taking
on all those responsibilities
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so in addition to the
narrow focus of the bill you said
um that the customer generator language
that seems to be contentious here was
really mirroring or emulating the
language that was in the original sb91 I
thought in your testimony you stated
that
so it it makes it non it's not unique
it's intentional that you
from our perspective it's it's certainly
not new so again the language that I was
looking at that's in the original Law
um is on line starting at the end of
line five where it says that shares
equipment or facilities with other
generators we're adding in energy
storage facilities again this is just
sharing equipment
um with these with Gen other generators
energy storage facilities or electric
utility customers for interconnection to
the electric grid shall be eligible to
participate in net energy metering as a
customer generator and then it goes on
so that language is all originally in SB
91 and
um so The Language online 12 through 14
is just further clarification that was
sought thank you
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um I was just just this mostly just for
clarification just to make sure there's
no issue of slippery slope I'm looking
at 362 A9 and I'm also looking at this
bill and I know it does not mention
White Mountain or Brookfield and where
in this bill or as far as I can find
36289 so what sets the limitations to
where it's only affecting these two
right so
um so this issue of the Legacy wiring
that I've been talking about where you
have multiple Hydro facilities behind a
single interconnection point to the grid
and that interconnection point in both
cases is the as a paper mill we've been
you know talking about this issue for
for a number of years
um and I represent the granite state
hydropower Association as well which is
the association of small-scale hydro
here in New Hampshire and
um
you know it's not to say that there's
not somebody out there hiding under a
rock that hasn't been paying attention
but um I I'm not aware of any other
situations which have this Legacy wiring
problem it does seem to be uh you know
it when you think about the history of
New Hampshire with all of our Mills and
those being powered by Hydro facilities
um you know a lot of them have been
upgraded over the years but in in
um and ownership maybe has
um
between Mills and the Hydra facilities
have stayed together on under one
umbrella but
um
this is just a legacy wiring problem
that uh
that we have here and I just add that
the
the language also of course includes a
commercial operation date that is 2021
or before and then obviously the the
program sizing requirements as well okay
thank you
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question you keep mentioning this
Legacy wiring issue is there anything
that's stopping uh that from being fixed
and being brought up to what you would
say I guess today's way of doing it and
you keep mentioning Antiques and so
forth so uh what's preventing you from
just making the fix yourself so so the
sites obviously are up to date as as
needed for safe operations there's new
metering at each of the the stations and
whatnot
um the reality is uh the two of the
facilities actually interconnect through
the mill and then each of them all
interconnect to the same
substation for us to do this separately
would be economically not feasible and
and provide sort of no uh you know
operational difference
follow-up so what you're saying is that
you could do it but it's too expensive
and you you could qualify under the
existing net metering laws if you made
that change is that correct that is by
understanding I mean we've never looked
at in detail at a high level we've seen
the numbers and said yes that it's not
right thank you
representative Summers remember to turn
off your microphone when you're not
speaking
all right further questions from the
committee
seeing none I'd like to call next on
Michael Licata representing eversource
to give us his perspective on this
legislation
good morning uh Michael Licata
representing eversource uh here in
support of the bill I'll be brief in my
comments because I do not want to be
repetitive I think Mr Roberts and Miss
Crowell did an excellent job outlining
the background and what the bill is
trying to to solve for
really ever source's interests here are
focused on getting accurate metering
data out of the generation facilities
which exists behind the retail meters as
you've heard from both Mr Roberts and
Miss Crowell
uh
there is uh
net metering qualified generation and
generation that does not qualify for net
metering all behind the retail meter and
so eversource we don't have insight into
the electricity that's being put back
onto our distribution system the the
source of that and so what the bill
tries to do or solve for is allow for
the customer or the generator to read
the existing Revenue grade meters which
are very accurate meters that are used
to enable these facilities to
participate in the regional markets read
those meters and then provide that data
to eversource on a monthly basis so then
we can build them appropriately and
apply net metering credits appropriately
and that's all subject to a methodology
that gets filed with the utility in the
department of energy and gets approval
and just to ensure the accuracy of that
data the bill further lays out the
ability to audit that data on an annual
basis as requested by the department of
energy so
that is our our interest is really
trying to get as Miss Kroll
talked about this sort of unique
metering or wiring arrangement to get
accurate data on what generator is
producing the electricity that gets
put back onto our distribution system
and then again accurately providing them
with the appropriate compensation as
laid out in SB 91 which was passed in
2021 and with that I'd be happy to
answer any questions the committee may
have
thank you appreciate your being here
today testifying before the committee I
have a quick question for you it's a
sort of a repetition of a question I
asked earlier from the utility point of
view what would happen to the
interconnection point if White Mountain
paper was to shut down
uh so white it's a good question I think
I need to touch base with folks uh back
at the office White Mountain paper is
the customer of record they have the
retail meter
um assuming no one takes over the plant
and it just sits dormant
um I I would have to double check it's
possible that
um at that point Brookfield could take
over that retail meter although you
would still have that same uh issue
where you have the single
interconnection point and then multiple
generators behind that meter
okay thank you additional questions now
from the committee representative
Harrington has one thank you thank you
for taking my question you mentioned a
couple of times your this would give you
more accurate data so I'm a little
confused what are you doing now just
guessing I mean it must be something
you're using to measure this amount now
we're not providing them with net
metering credits today so uh essentially
what ever gets used on site Whatever
Gets produced they're not getting that
metering credits today so we don't have
to track essentially What entity is
producing that electricity behind the
meter okay follow-up
follow up so the need for accurate data
only exists if this bill were to pass
and they would be eligible for net
metering as it is right now it's not an
issue is that correct so the the issue
stems from the passage of Senate Bill 91
back in 2021 which made these facilities
eligible for net metering however as Ms
Kroll said we haven't been able to
implement that public policy decision
because we don't have the accurate
meeting metering data
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chair so is it possible to
put a meter on the output of each of the
individual Hydro facilities
so that is possible but as uh was
testified by others uh that would
essentially make
have economic implications that uh would
be essentially expensive for them to
comply with
the cost of the meter itself would be
that I mean I understand the
interconnection issue but so they they
have meters on them now uh that the
customer owns or the generator owns I
should say uh the revenue grade meters
that are being used uh when the
facilities I understand it participate
in Regional markets so metering does
exist they're not ever sources meters in
order for us to to wire and and have our
own meters at each individual location
uh would be would be expensive for the
the customer
follow up
so is it possible for you to you agree
that the meters are good quality meters
is it possible for you to use
readings from those meters even though
you don't own them correct and that is
what the bill
authorizes it authorizes the customer or
the generator to read their revenue
grade meters and then provide that data
data to eversource on a monthly basis
under a methodology approved by the
department of energy so that we can
compensate them accurately
okay
follow up again
one clarification needed
so
then
the the hydro facility would be the
customer generator we're not talking
about
White Mountain paper being the the the
uh the customer it's white it's it's the
actual Hydro facility
so under the bill correct the facility
would be the customer generator and in
the case of uh
Brookfield and uh White Mountain paper
one is the customer of record that own
that we we build with a retail meter
behind that retail meter are the
generation generators owned by
Brookfield
thank you
okay representative Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question for clarification
you said something earlier that kind of
confused me you said that under the
previous bills that's Bill 91 that both
entities already qualified for net
medium for net metering
correct so if if that is true then what
would be the need for lines 12 through
that seems to be in dispute right now
so to to answer the first part
um the as I understand it the intention
of Senate Bill 91 was to allow
these hydroelectric facilities to
qualify for net metering in excess of
one megawatt
and the challenge was that again as I
and others described we we don't have a
way to accurately meter
without a change in legislation
um the the output of those facilities
the the second part of your question
representative Thomas about uh lines 12
through 15.
um
I I believe that that language uh
is intended to make it clear that uh the
use of the term customer generator which
exists in statute applies to these
facilities so uh makes additional
clarification above uh the language that
you see lines three through twelve which
aside from the additions of energy
storage facilities
is is the language from Senate bill 91.
seems to make it more unclear but
thank you okay additional questions from
the committee representative munz has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for being here again
um the the bill talks about incremental
costs relative to a manual billing
process and I think you alluded to that
as well in your in your testimony
those costs that you would be incurring
is that are those above and beyond what
you normally would incur for a net
metering in it for a net metering
situation yeah so uh it's it's
consistent with the costs that the
utilities incur for for similar
arrangements so essentially all group
net metering is a manual process so it's
it's spreadsheets it's folks taking
information from one system and entering
it into another and doing the manual
billing process and this would be be
quite consistent so we'll be getting a
spreadsheet from
um from the generator under the
methodology approved by the department
of energy and employees will be entering
that data and manually building so it is
consistent with and as Ms Kroll said is
consistent with the cost recovery of
those
um of that existing process
follow-up
follow-up so so is it fair to say then
that there would be no additional cost
to utility customers
because of this special arrangement
and then they might otherwise incur so
the additional there there would be
I I would say
it is consistent with
the additional costs already incurred
essentially what we're talking about is
an employee taking a spreadsheet and
doing data entry on a monthly basis it
is not
significant dollars and it is consistent
with other forms of net metering how we
process that at billing I mean it's it
would be
not significant uh in terms of money I
would say in the thousands not tens of
thousands of dollars
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Licata for taking my question
my question is around whether there's
any value to be gained of having Hydro
energy going on back on the grid because
my understanding is that right now that
Hydro is probably pricing lower
than some other forms of energy that we
have going through the system to produce
electricity so can you speak to that do
you know what the
what what the cost of of hydro is going
for
yeah I
I really can't speak to it and it's
great to see you back on the committee
representative
um so I just
certainly I think
um RPS qualified small-scale Hydro in
New Hampshire is a fantastic resource
which is why the
legislature had you know specifically uh
called it out as part of the state RPS
and it has its own class and own uh
alternative compliance payment structure
so uh it is a a very good resource as
folks said it uh Mr Griffin I think
Robert said it has a higher capacity
Factor than other forms of renewable
generation and certainly provides a
benefit in terms of the specific pricing
that these facilities uh are sort of
providing for their energy it really
I think some have purchased power
arrangements with either municipality or
commercial generator others if they're
small enough can net meter
um others still might bid into the
regional market
um so it's it's kind of a grab bag here
we're talking about these um
specific locations getting getting the
uh
net metering compensation between one
megawatt and five megawatts and okay
cool thank you very much thanks before I
uh call on the last person who wants to
speak to us about this bill I want to
address what
everyone must have noticed by now and
that is that we are running way behind
schedule so
Senate Bill 68 which was scheduled for
10 a.m is obviously now about an hour
eight minutes behind
69 which was scheduled for 10 30 is
behind that as is 79 so it doesn't look
like we're going to get to those bills
before the lunch break
we might start the hearing on 68 before
the lunch break I have over a dozen pink
cards for Senate Bill 68 by itself
so it's obviously going to turn into a
longer day than what we had originally
hoped
but I just wanted everyone everyone who
is in the room here today and everybody
watching from elsewhere to know
what uh the plan is for the rest of the
day and with that we'll call on Mr David
cuzzy as the last speaker on this bill
to give us his perspective on this
legislation
thank you Mr chairman good morning
members of the committee my name is Dave
cuzzy with Prospect Hill strategies here
in town this morning uh before you on
behalf of White Mountain paper
um
White Mountain paper I guess this was uh
as was stated previously where a paper
manufacturing company so we don't have a
dog in this fight except that we've now
this has become I guess to be
oversimplifying our problem or
partly our problem and
um so that's fine we have a good working
relationship with Brookfield and that
has allowed us to come to an agreement
on language should this bill go forward
that satisfies the concerns of White
Mountain paper and gets us to a position
of really no position on the bill the
concerns were very simple for White
Mountain uh we just as you may recall
when we testify when I testified on
behalf of the mill on House Bill 458 we
were concerned we needed to make sure
that this did not to confirm the
suspicion that this bill would not
impact the power purchase agreement
that's in place through I believe 2031
and that is that is the case this would
not impact that PPA
the other concern was and this is
perhaps a little bit more nebulous but
how would this impact
the mill after the PPA just like any
other business or well is the access to
clean reliable and I guess affordable
for New England but affordable power is
of the essence of being able to do
business and of course if you're in the
the paper manufacturing business in the
North Country even more important uh
just given the volatility of that
industry though the mill is on a path to
sustainability and perhaps even growth
the need for the mill to make sure that
it was going to have access to that
power after the PPA was was Paramount
if I may Mr chairman I just want to take
a minute to address some of the
questions that were posed to other uh
testifiers
um I have a I believe it was you Mr
chairman asked what happens if the mill
goes out of business and you know of
course no one wants that but it's a
reasonable question I would respectfully
suggest that
um
if the mill were to go out of business
the assets are still owned by uh Mr
Behrens the the owner of the of the mill
and he would he or his
company would still be the customer
utility of record at the interconnection
and that is an asset that would be sold
if the it would be in play so I don't
just because the mill may not be
operating doesn't mean that all of a
sudden Brookfield just becomes
the customer of record I'm not an
attorney but that would be my assumption
that that's still part of the property
and there still would be uh you know the
owner of that facility would still need
power just to make sure the buildings
are are safe and whatnot
um so I wanted to address that
um
representative I believe you asked the
question about you know why not just
open up the PPA and uh you know for for
White Mountain again this was I guess
not necessarily our problem to solve
respectfully I don't mean to be trite uh
but
uh just making sure that the company had
to spend thousands of dollars on
attorneys on attorney fees just to make
sure
we got to a position where we are today
the PPA was many thousands of dollars to
negotiate that a few years ago and it
was just not an expense the company saw
the need to uh to do for a problem that
you know really isn't isn't theirs if
you will but happy to do so for the
point of this legislation
um you know to work cooperatively with
with Brookfield
um
so that really Mr chairman is is well I
think the the questions that uh I heard
I I believe representative bonds may
have had one that I'm and I'm blanking
on that that I meant to address and I
apologize
um on the underlying policy concerns
regarding if it's the legality or
constitutionality of the bill or the
amendment
um or the overarching policy discussion
about the definition of customer
generator White Mountain as you might
expect uh has no no position on that so
I just want to make that clear that the
goal really was to make sure that
uh very simply been I know this sounds
selfish but our interests of course were
protected
um Brookfield negotiated with us in good
faith to make sure that uh it was
clarified that they were only talking
about excess generation and that the
needs of the mill are served whether
it's zero
or you know double or more what it is
right now we wanted to make sure that
that was that that was something that
protected the mill uh and that that's
all I had for my remarks Mr chairman
thank you
thank you Mr cousin we appreciate you
being here this morning we have some
questions for you representative
Harrington has one thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question um we
keep talking about this PPA so what
exactly what's the price that's being
paid there thank you for the question
representative I don't know the answer
to that I could certainly get that uh
assuming that that both parties are
comfortable sharing all right well
people are asking to a special attention
from the state to have a bill passed
just for them so I think that
information should be shared with the
public fair point but although to be
clear White Mountain paper is not asking
uh not asking for that but I'll I'll get
I'll get that info to the extent I can
thank you
representative Munns has a question
thank you Mr chair and
don't feel bad about blanking on my
question because that happens to me all
the time with my wife so thank you
that's going to say the same thing about
me
um
but on the PPA
um so you know what I heard you say and
and I don't want to put words in your
mouth well I heard you say was it was
the cost to actually negotiate the PPA
the legal expenses that was a concern of
White Mountain if those costs were paid
by someone else
um would that remove your reluctance to
open up the PPA and maybe talk about a
solution that does not require a
legislative solution
it would remove a
a barrier or a concern but I I think
as you know we were going through this
on the White Mountain Side you know
they're they're trying to keep a mill
sustainable and that gets the attention
right up to the owner and so I think the
the thought of opening up a PPA that was
um you know took quite a lot of time and
effort to come to agreement on just
two years ago two years ago
um is just not something that anyone
thinks would be a good use of of
anyone's time I think
you know the concern is that all these
administrative
really what you'd be talking about is
you'd be shifting a lot of the
administrative burden onto
White Mountain and
it's just not something that they're
interested in doing even if it were
somehow done by someone else it just
becomes very difficult and just not
something that the mill
wants or needs in terms of its focus on
making that Mill sustainable uh and and
even uh you know position for growth
down the road which is really what's
most important for the North Country I'd
respectfully suggest
I don't know I hope that answers your
question I'm happy to give it another
shot if you like well if follow-up
follow up well I guess what I'm trying
to understand and I appreciate that this
isn't this isn't your your your hunt
um but um trying to see if there's a way
if there's you know if a way where
you're kept whole where you know any
additional costs any additional effort
that you know you're required to do if
you're kept whole is there is there
possibly a solution that doesn't involve
as representative Harrington said you
know the legislature basically creating
a special provision
for uh you know one one particular
situation in a vacuum respectfully
sure
um but I you know again respectfully not
operating in a vacuum
I guess that that still would be a path
I just I guess what I'm saying
representative is that I don't think
it's a path the mill has any interest in
in taking I I suppose anything's
possible but as we sit here today I I
just I don't see that path and I I
believe
that that Brookfield shares that I don't
mean to be speaking for Brookfield but I
think they made comments similar to that
prior
thank you
okay seeing no further questions from
the committee I want to thank you very
much for being here to testify thank you
Mr chairman
and with that since we have no more pink
cards on this bill
I will uh close the public hearing on
this legislation and ask representative
closure to give us a count on the
previous two bills Senate Bill 16 and
Senate Bill 40 with regard to Blue sheet
information
thank you chair Senate bill 16. blue
sheep was one in support one opposed
online three and support one neutral
Senate Bill 40
the blue sheep
or in support one oppose online 42 in
support zero a pulse thank you chair
okay thank you so let's move along here
and
I'm going to open a public hearing on
Senate Bill 68 relative to Municipal
host
purpose for purposes of limited
electrical energy producers
representative partial did you have a
question yes thank you chair that's for
those that have come in more recently
could you repeat uh your for earlier
comments about how we're running late we
will be running over the Lunch Period
okay so we are running late
originally this public hearing was
scheduled for 10 a.m it's now 11 21.
we will start this public hearing now I
have at least a dozen pink cards of
folks who want to testify on this uh
particular piece of legislation so it's
going to be a while before we finish
this bill
and we will probably take a lunch break
in the middle of this Public public
hearing so we'll start it now we'll
complete it after lunch
and then we'll move on to the second the
other two bills on the calendar which
are 69 and 79 sometime this afternoon
so let's get the show started by calling
on Senator Waters to introduce this
legislation which was originally
sponsored by senator avard
so Senator Waters
give us a an indication of what this
bill is all about thank you thank you Mr
chairman members of the committee I'm
introducing this on behalf of Senator
avard the once again I was a co-sponsor
along with the senator pearl of this
bill this is
maybe not quite a technical change but
as it changes the definition of
Municipal host as you will see in line
six through eight in the bill it strikes
the municipal hose shall be located in
the same municipality as all group
members if the facility began operating
after January 1st 20
21. and as as you know well that one
Governor sununu signed uh House Bill 315
Municipal net metering projects were
expanded uh to allowed up to five
megawatts we know from the industry by
this point the three to five megawatts
is the kind of sweet spot where these
projects uh can deliver low-cost energy
that can still under our statues be
integrated into the power grid the the
issue with the definition here is that
some Municipal
um hosts are having difficulty finding
enough use of the power under this
definition
by Partners to be able to hit that three
to five megawatts where the project
makes Financial
um sense so what it would let you do is
kind of team up and enter into that
metering projects with some other
entities for example let's say a group
of saus
or let's say a city hall plus a
wastewater treatment plant that might
serve a community but not be in a
municipality admissible area
um that if they could put a partnership
together like this or a hospital and
some other entity then they would be
able to
um
have a project and sell the energy back
into the grid
um and you know just for background
there are about 10 Municipal hosts net
metering projects in New Hampshire right
now so we know this works and the
feeling is that this change would allow
more municipalities under the five
megawatt limit to have financially
feasible and keep power lower in cost
for uh customers in New Hampshire so
that is it Mr chairman
thank you Senator Waters a good
explanation of a relatively simple bill
questions from the committee
representative Harrington has one thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question you said something and maybe it
was just a misspoke you said if they
were to go with a hospital but my
reading of this bill it would have to be
a excuse me political subdivision my
error I don't know I think I was
thinking another bill we're going to
have thank you but my Aaron thank you
for correctly Mr representative
Harrington
representative Summers has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh just just recently in the house we we
had hb139 and we looking at that this
actually this bill and other than adding
The quasi-public Entity and we just
argued this in the house it seems It's
the exact same bill the exact same
change so just a limit questioning is
that the only change or difference
um you know I just looked at 139 but I
don't have a thanks for your question I
don't have it in uh right in front of me
but um I think what is different here is
that um
located in the same municipality
okay I think that's different and not
maybe I'd be wrong about that
representative Summers did you have a
follow-up
um yes it does have the uh it basically
strikes out the exact same line that you
have struck out here
um the only thing it adds is the housing
authority and a quasi-public entity so
um and uh the peas Development Authority
um I know we just had this on the house
last house session this already went
through and we passed it through and we
went through committee here
um but uh just wanted to see if these
are basically two mirrored bills and it
looks like they just about are
further questions from the committee
seeing none we'll move along since we
have a lot well representative Bernardi
has a question thank you Mr chairman so
do you have an estimated number of how
many uh uh potential new facilities
would
would be interested in this particular
revision
uh no I don't and um
you know it's an individual decision by
a municipality
um I expect that there will be interest
I think considering what we have seen
about Community power and the reduction
of costs available through that and new
entities joining Community power that
there might be further interest for
those communities to look at this
program as well to not just purchase
power to benefit their Community but
also to start doing some of these
projects as well so
I don't know but I I suspect that people
will that this would be a
um a good way to let these things become
economically feasible for more
municipalities
thank you
okay I have a question for you Senator
we keep hearing
and I think you referred to this
yourself and your testimony that
municipalities don't have enough load to
build a five megawatt system
well let's assume that a municipality
had 1.5 megawatts of load why don't they
just build a 1.5 megawatt system why do
they need to build a five megawatt
system
well um thanks for the question Mr
chairman and I I think we may have some
industry folks on your list but you know
I think it's very clear
that the economics
um of of that size system doesn't really
cut it to get a low price at actual
lower energy costs for the air for the
for the users
um I will give you an example that I
know of in my own Community where there
was a question about if we put solar at
the highest the new High School
um then would that would the could the
project be done at what level
and how many megawatts that the investor
was willing to build the project and the
power would be something that would
undercut the cost of other available
power and I and I think that you know
the what Dover and some other
communities have gone through is that
you just really can't make the numbers
work very well and that's that is in
fact why under 315 Mr chairman we raised
it up to five megawatts because uh the
industry was telling us that this is you
know as I said before three to five
megawatts is a sweet spot where the
numbers work that's the way the industry
works
well my follow-up question would be I
was reading the contract
that Rockingham County has written with
revision energy to put in a five
megawatt system at the new County
Complex that would be built over the
next two years
and the price tag on that system was 10
million dollars which is a significant
amount of money
and
I guess my question would be
assuming that the County Complex uses
most if not all of that five megawatts
uh
how does Net metering help
make this
project more affordable
well thanks for your question and
you know I can't speak to the Rockingham
project
uh and I
I in a sense think that we you know we
make certain things possible through
legislation that seem to make sense to
us and potentially reduce costs for New
Hampshire consumers I mean that's that's
what that's what we're all about when it
comes to electricity policy in fact it's
in statute that's what we should be all
about
seems to me that what we do with this
legislation is we let municipalities
make a business decision
if they can't make the numbers work
they they don't do it if the if the
builders
look at a project look at Supply
channels have cost and say we we just
can do it for this cost but we can't do
it for that that cost those are business
decisions
I do think the evidence has shown that
it's it has been an experience of New
Hampshire and the spouse has done this
already that the three to five
megawatt is the area which it starts to
become cost effective now I'm I'm not in
this business we'll hear from others who
are are but that seems to be the case
and that's why here if we make this
technical change that you can put
together a group of people that'll help
you make those numbers seems to me a
pretty good bill
okay I guess we can pursue this line of
question with questioning with some
other folks as well
uh representative Reynolds looks like he
has a question
thank you Mr chairman I I'd like to ask
a question it's kind of a follow-up to
your question if if I may to of Senator
Waters isn't it
you're understanding
uh
what you just said about three to five
megawatts being the the sort of the
sweet spot where it becomes cost
effective isn't that because a
significant part of the cost of any
project is actually the interconnection
cost of that project to the grid and
that's a cost that the that the uh
neither the municipality or the builder
of the system really controls that's a
cost that the you that the utility gives
to the developers of the project to
interconnect and it's a significant cost
is that why the scale matters so much
thanks for your question and I'm sure
you will hear from
the industry folks that this has been a
red line and stopped some projects I
know very much about one and over that
the County Complex wanted to do and if
you're that first customer in you're
bearing the whole cost you are going to
see later a bill from the Senate which
attempts to look at that issue because
it is an important one I'll just say in
reference a number of years ago
a colleague in the Republican colleague
and the Senate and I put together a bill
that was a kind of an analog situation
where
if you were the first person to bring in
the infrastructure for a mall
development then subsequent people
coming into that development you could
you could get a portion of your original
expense now we passed that and I think
it's kind of analogous to hear but
you'll see in the subsequent bill from
the Senate
um a study group that's set up to look
at that with the utilities and so on
because it is a there's an issue of
fairness there I think
but okay thank you
okay additional questions
seeing none we thank you Senator Waters
we'll let you go so you can get some
lunch so you see your lunch after lunch
and next we're going to call on The
Honorable Lee oxenham from Plainfield
New Hampshire to
come to talk to us about this bill since
she made a long drive from Plainfield
and I'm sure she would like to get home
um before dark so uh
representative oxenham the floor is
yours
former representative occident thank you
very much Mr chair delighted to be here
and thank you for taking my testimony
many of you will be familiar with the
map
okay all set
many of you will be familiar with the
map I just circulated you will recall
last spring we had a similar bill and I
think that's the the text that you may
have been referring to about
quasi-public entities and peas
Development Authority this is a clean
bill it doesn't have those um issues
which raise controversy last year as our
chair will recall we we're down to the
wire we were looking at an amendment on
the bill and there was a a consensus of
the committee a bipartisan consensus
that we liked this bill we thought it
was appropriate to allow municipalities
to work together when they don't have
sufficient load on their own
uh but that those those that particular
language created issues so uh our chair
said that if no other sponsor came
forward he would submit this bill
himself as a clean bill which only has
the language that we have before us
today so I hope that we can return to
that lovely morning in May when we were
all agreeing on the importance of this
text and we can move this bill forward
the importance of the map the yellow is
Liberty the blue is eversource and the
pink is the co-op there's a little
yellow island in the center of the map
and that is the small amount of Liberty
territory that is in Cornish that's the
area where we are hoping to put an array
the Two Towns working together as you
can tell it's impossible for for for
this bill for for the entity to be
sustainable in the municipality of
Cornish the the large territory that
could sustain this array is in
Plainfield in Lebanon and in Enfield
so um I I bring this to your attention
strictly as an illustration many of our
small towns across the state are in the
same place they have multiple
territories we all understand you have
to keep these group post Arrangements
within the territory of the utility but
there is the putting superimposing the
municipal boundary just creates an
obstacle a constraint which has meant
that only 10 towns in the state have
been able to move forward and the rest
of us have been left unable to proceed
with cost-effective solutions to our
issues of high electricity costs and
lack of diversity uh in our supply the
the only other issue I wanted to bring
forward for your attention today was
that once again in the fiscal note we
have the issue of potential cost
shifting I had hoped we had laid this
one to rest we had the vder study that
came came out last year after years of
oh let's not make any decisions on that
one let's wait until the vdr study comes
out we have the vder study there is no
significant cost shifting let's take
that off the table
and I will also just bring your
attention in the dunski study that it
mentioned there are numerous additional
benefits which are not costed in so when
they say there's no significant cost
shifting
that take doesn't even begin to go to
the additional benefits with more
renewable energy in less criteria
pollutants less greenhouse gases reduced
load reduced Peaks increased Health
lower hospitalizations for children
across the state we all know renewable
energy is coming the clean energy
Revolution is moving forward in all the
states around us it's time for New
Hampshire not to be the laggard this is
a good bill please support it it was
supported last year we had a problem
with some anomalous language that's gone
it's a clean bill please move ahead with
it thank you
thank you questions for The Honorable MS
oxenham
representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and nice to see
you again representative oxenham
um Okay so
uh as was mentioned with the opening
speaker with Senator Waters there were
two bills that were really sister or
companion bills one on the house side
and one on the other side of the wall
this is the other side of the wall
um and and the bill that we submitted
um
did have the problematic language still
in it but it also passed so it did
receive enough support to get through
the house so I guess
um my question was
um
well it sounds like you would support
either Bill if they could make it
through to the governor's desk right
you're absolutely correct okay but uh I
understand and I just want to clarify I
think you're correct that perhaps this
language is cleaner for us to consider
moving forward with because usually only
one of the bills actually
goes all the way through and so would it
be your preference that it be this bill
oh uh
I I guess I would say so I I think that
can be left to a committee of conference
I don't think that's a that's good it's
not a showstopper the bill needs to move
forward and if both go forward yeah well
that's uh up benefit of riches
further questions good enough MS oxenham
seeing none we want to thank you for
making the long drive from Plainfield
and it was nice to see you again thank
you sir very nice to see all of you
thank you for your work next I'll call
on Griffin Roberge from the Department
of energy to give us the Department's
perspective on this legislation
uh thank you uh Mr chairman members of
the committee again Griffin Roberge
strategy program manager at the
department of energy Department of
energy is opposed to Senate Bill 68 FN
is introduced as I believe everybody is
well aware now uh State Statute
currently permits a municipal host uh
with a total Peak generating capacity of
greater than one megawatt less than five
to serve as a group host to offset the
electricity requirements of a group of
members that consist exclusively of
political subdivisions and these
Municipal hosts can be publicly or
privately owned
um as has been mentioned the statute was
originally created under house bill 315
from 2021 and modified further by House
Bill 1258 last year to include the state
of New Hampshire as a political
subdivision
um the bills really only change is on
line six to eight um removing the
statutory language that requires a
municipal host must be located in the
same municipality is all political
subdivisions or group members if the
facility began operation after January 1
of 2021.
um this change would allow for newly
constructed generation serving as a
municipal host to have group members
outside of the same municipality that
the host is located in obviously
providing that they're all within the
same franchise territory
um much like our testimony on House Bill
139 when it was before this committee
the department opposes any changes to
States net metering statute at this time
there is an ongoing docket de
22060 that is pending before the Public
Utilities Commission that will consider
changes to the current net metering
tariff structure including compensation
to customer generators and it will also
take into account the outcome of the
vder study and determine to what extent
cost shifting is occurring
um again doe much like we have on many
of the other net metering bills suggests
letting suggest to policy makers to let
the puc process play out before making
any changes to the state's net metering
statute and for further context s has
been mentioned there are 10 currently
registered Municipal hosts in the state
they are located in Manchester Milton
Berlin Gorham Hillsborough Canaan
bosquin Hooksett Penacook in Durham
um and that concludes my testimony happy
to take any questions
thank you questions for Mr Roberge
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you for the big
question
and I guess we will ask us that every as
every Bill comes by here
when will that docket be completed
that's fair
um I believe that there have been I'm
trying to recall off the top of my head
I can certainly follow up with more
specific information but I believe there
will be likely significant progress by
around this time next year but I'd have
to take a further look I don't want to
speak out of term I can follow up with
the committee by any with an email
further questions from the committee
representative McGee has one thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr robesch
um my question is around the the
opposition to there being an expansion
of these types of projects and whether
it comes from an energy standpoint or
from an economic standpoint because I
know the most recent 10-year strategy
report that you guys put out you know
the number one bullet was was um you
know costs sure and so I think a lot of
people are pursuing these projects in
order to lower costs for municipalities
and so I'm just wondering why the
opposition would be focused on trying to
limit our ability to to
uh you know extend people the ability to
do these projects no for that purpose
and I thank you for that question so I
think I don't really think it's well I
think there's an economic aspect to it
but I think it's more of a procedural
opposition is that there's a current
adjudicative proceeding at the Public
Utilities Commission which will look at
this issue very in-depth Department of
energy is also a party to that as well
as many other stakeholders groups I'm
sure many of them are in this room
um you know the puc is designed as a
forum by which all of these parties can
fully adjudicate these issues and they
are Technical and very complex and
address these issues in a in a forum
um again through the Judiciary
proceeding I think we'd prefer to let
that process play out before making any
uh real changes to the state's net
metering statute while that proceeding
is ongoing and obviously the vder study
uh came out late last year you know I
know that there's been some discussion
about about whether or not
um that should be the end of it that the
vdr answered it that there's no cost
shift
I think the department views the the the
the vder study as a piece of the puzzle
that the puc is ultimately putting
together they are going to arrive at
potential changes to the St uh to the
net metering tariff structure look
further into uh the impacts that
um cost shifting may may have
um across different
um customers
um the other thing I just want to know
is that you know I know p i I will admit
the vder study did not find significant
levels of cautious but there was a one
percent cost shift uh that they
identified
um and again the puc will consider that
in its adjudicated proceeding and
overall the department would prefer
letting that process play out before
making any policy changes
okay uh representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr Roberts once again so you said that
we're looking at the puc docket going on
for about another year
and and I assume it's already been in
process for a while it's I should I mean
to interrupt I'm sorry I thought there'd
be another question after I want to cut
you off okay I'm sorry well I'm just
wondering uh it seems like this is
taking a long time and given that the
legislature gets to set policy
I'm just wondering why should we be
waiting for the puc to take so long when
we can actually
decide to do this on our own and and
thank you for the question so I will
obviously concede as I have in the past
you folks here are the policy makers you
can determine
um the policy as you see fit um
obviously the department was created a
couple years ago to provide a unified
policy direction to policy makers to the
extent uh policy makers want to go a
different route that's obviously their
jurisdiction
um regarding the the docket 22060 it's
my understanding that that was that was
a me that was opened late last year with
an order from the Public Utilities
Commission I believe that there's been
some ongoing discussion as to hearing
schedules and that type of thing but
that obviously will be a little bit of
of a process again this is not something
that's
these aren't easy matters to to address
I mean they're very technical very
complex very overwhelming so you know
the puc is designed for this
um they undertake adjudicative
proceedings to fully vet these issues
stakeholders to the extent that they're
comfortable can take part as interveners
in all of these cases and I think the
department would just submit laying that
process play out before making any
substantial policy changes
okay thank you seeing no further
questions for Mr robarge thank you
I'm going to suspend the public hearing
on Center Bill 68 and I'm going to
open the public hearing as a courtesy to
our Senate colleagues I'm going to open
the public hearing to Senate Bill 69 and
ask Senator Waters to introduce the
legislation
thank you Mr chairman I truly appreciate
the opportunity to come in now Senator
Waters District before introducing
Senate Bill 69 on behalf of Senator Avon
and I guess it's turning into net
metering morning and house Ste and uh I
think we certainly are going to need to
have some ongoing conversations about
what we do about both House and Senate
bills on these matters
um what this does
um and you will see it uh changes the
definition of customer
um generator uh online seven and eight
except is provided for a non-profit host
as defined in paragraph 2G what are
non-profit hosts going to be well
paragraph 2G non-profit host means a
customer generator a total Peak
generated in capacity so
um you know non-profit folks located in
the same utility franchise service
Terrace territory so you can't be a
non-profit in one part of New Hampshire
and then go into a different utility
service or out of state or something
it's uh that's an important definition
um
there and um
the non-profit entities included are
listed uh there as as well
um
note at the on lines 20 to 22
we have Technical College College
University Hospitals as defined in RSA
151 colon 2 which is why I always
thinking hospitals earlier sorry about
that
um and then
um done
uh housing authorities bona fide
religious organizations and the peace
Development Authority
so that is what it it would do
um it seems that
look at each of those entities being
able to take advantage of uh this
program would save money for our
communities because these are
non-profits that are serving our
communities
and I think in particular I just had a
conversation the other day with
Restoration Church pastors and they have
built some recovery housing and uh you
know I think about the kinds of ways in
which there's a lot of open rooftops and
a lot of churches as you might see it as
providing lower cost power
um for their car you know to do their
operation but also for ancillary
activities that might benefit the public
that one seems pretty important plus
you're familiar with conversations
around peas and around the housing
authorities so that's what it does Mr
chairman let me do note that we had no
opposition to this bill in the Senate
and as on Senate Bill 68 and now on
Senate Bill 69 Josh Elliott
representative Department of energy on
both bills as being neutral
on this so whatever other conversations
there are that's what we heard in the
Senate thank you Mr chairman
questions for Senator water is
representative Corman has one thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Senator Waters
I read the Senate hearing report yeah
and what I gathered from that was that
there there was an amendment to the bill
is introduced and the Amendments the
amendment really just added
clarification about hospitals and Bona
Fida religious organizations
um but what I saw in the hearing in the
Senate hearing report was that somehow
the amended bill was going to clarify
that non-profits can combine with
municipalities to form a group host and
I'm just not understanding how adding
hospitals and religious organizations
clarifies that nonprofits can combine
with municipalities to form group hosts
you know um
I am not sure that I recall that
conversation within the hearing what I
worked on in that amendment I mean as
it's Senator avard's Bill was making
sure the same utility franchise service
territory that was an important one for
us and I believe that was part of the uh
some Amendment we were working on as
well but I I don't have it in front of
me but
what you see is what you get and I think
that keeping it kind of exclusive to
non-profits really probably makes some
sense here
further questions representative munz
has one thank you Mr chair and thank you
again Senator Waters
um
was there any discussion in the senate
about clarifying
a little bit more exactly exactly what a
non-profit is I mean I I was struck by
the fact that unless it's defined
someplace else but I was struck by the
fact that there was no requirement that
it be red that it'd be an organization
that's registered with the New Hampshire
Department of Justice's charitable trust
unit or have an IRS
non-profit designation
um
I I'm you know I've had a lot of
experience with non-profits on boards
and so on and I believe that you do have
to register to have that status and uh
I'm not sure there's a specific unless
I'm
not
understanding each of the statutes that
are referenced here
um
but if if uh if there is an explicit
reference to that definition there
probably ought to be but we do have that
in statute what qualifies as a
non-profit and how you're registered
with the secretary of state
follow-up follow-up
so is that a is that a a potential
amendment that you could support where
even if we just included a you know
something that says non-profit as
defined in
no that that only addresses hospitals
oh well it's
see I think that it was down around 28 I
think that just referring back up to
this end of this bill the 2G that we're
adding here
um in terms of the definition of
non-profit if if this doesn't already
in 362 A1 already defined that then I
think what you're suggesting makes sense
but I will say I cannot speak for
Senator Evart but I suspect that he
would want that clarified as well
further questions from the committee
represent representative Corman has
another one thank you Mr chairman and I
actually have a similar question to
representative Moses not about nonprofit
but what is a bona Fida religious
organization actually search the rsas to
see if there was a definition of that
and at least in State Statute I could
not find one and I'm just wondering you
know who decides you know can I just set
up the Church of Corman and apply
um
how many members do you expect to have
and do you want to do a net metering
it's Millions
um uh a good question I will defer that
to a chance to look at statute because
it may be as well that you want to the
point here is non-profit isn't it and
you look at
um
you look at the language before operate
as a not-for-profit or a non-profit so
that non-profit would describe what
follows after it including Bonafide
Buddhist organizations which I suspect
back to the previous question would um
be that such a bona fide religious
organizations that are registers
non-profits that seems to be the issue
not whether we're trying to Define what
a religious organization may qualify or
not and it may so I will look into the
statute about that again I will I'll
talk to Senator avard but that may be
something that needs clarification here
okay seeing no further questions I want
to thank you Senator waters for
introducing this bill and I'm going to
suspend thank you for accommodating you
bet I'm going to suspend this public
hearing until after lunch
and now I'm going to open a public
hearing on Senate Bill 79 and ask
representative Lang to introduce this
legislation and just uh so everybody
will be clear as to the process we're
also going to suspend this public
hearing as soon as Senator Lang
introduces the bill we're going to take
a lunch break then we're going to come
back and resume the Senate bill 68.
public hearing then when we finish that
we're going to resume the Senate Bill 69
public hearing and then when we finish
that we'll resume this public hearing
so that's what's going to happen over
the course of the rest of the day so
Senator Lang go ahead and introduce this
legislation thank you Mr chairman I take
back all the things I said out in the
hallway when I left and told I had to
come back at two o'clock and I guess
someone told me that makes me a true
center now is complaining about the
house so
um so thank you for taking my testimony
um so this bill
um is a manufacturing and Industrial
bill right so one of the things we've
all heard from our constituents is that
electric prices are through the roof and
that's even 10 times worse for our
businesses and so what this bill looks
to give them an alternative
um I keep I was thinking the net
metering bills are kind of like license
plate bills every time you allow
something add-on somebody's going to add
another request for a different type of
license plate this is the same thing for
net metering we're adding for looking
for another exemption to the one
megawatt limit
so probably the most important language
I think that's in here is if you're
looking at the the Senate bill is online
it's 18 18 and 19 what makes us
different and it says in no instance
shall electrical generation facility
exceed a hundred percent of the
industrial host's average electric
consumption over the past 12 months so
our goal here is not to make a revenue
stream I know with net metering group
net metering the argument's always been
the light bulb out in the field right
you put a light bulb out in the field
put a meter on it and then you throw a
five megawatt megawatt uh solar array
behind it and just generate revenue for
yourself that's not what we're looking
to do here what we're looking to do is
help our New Hampshire businesses reduce
their electrical costs so that they can
compete in our Market
um
I I will say we've been playing with
ways and means over in the senate about
same kind of language how can we help
these businesses through Capital
expenditures uh reduce some costs so
they can compete in in a in a market
that has that crosses state lines I
think this is one of the bills that can
do that
um where we can allow for businesses to
allow to generate enough electric
consumption up to their 100 capacity
whatever they use they can generate and
use the grid for the off and on so one
of the arguments is around how does this
help businesses so remember businesses
will generate electricity on Saturday
and Sunday when aren't necessarily open
so while they may consume 100
electricity or 80 electricity or 100 you
know there's a hundred they need 110 so
they're not generating enough and
pulling off the grid their weekend
generation will allow them to make that
back up and help them with their
electrical costs I'll remind you that
the puc has a docket open which I'm sure
you're all familiar with about studying
net metering rates and what's going to
be paid the idea again here isn't to pay
the retail rate and the high consumption
rate the ideal is to pay something
between wholesale and Retail to give
them an ability to
um
to pay pay for to offset their
electrical costs and again at the end of
the year
it's 100 capacity is where they're at so
it's anything over that they're going to
have to go down to the wholesale rate
which is I believe what the current net
metering statute does so in there so
happy to take questions a little bit
long-winded apologize but
thank you for introducing Senate Bill 79
representative munz has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you Senator at
the risk of being pigeonholed as the
definition guy
um in um in line 16 we talk about
commercial industrial or institutional
entities is it clear what those are
do we need to clarify that
so there's no um there is no specific uh
definition in New Year right Mr
definition
um and I I would argue that a license
would probably do that right so all of
our businesses have licenses in the
state of New Hampshire you have to
register with the Secretary of State's
office to do business in the state of
New Hampshire so that would probably be
where I would look for the definition
follow-up
follow up so that would be something
that you wouldn't be opposed to adding
some reference to
that not at all when this bill first
came out um I know the department of
energy had some problem Josh I think his
name is over there had some problems and
we amended the bill in the Senate to
take care of most of his concerns
um so I would have no objection to a
definition Amendment I'm just I I would
look to the Secretary of State's office
though to figure out how you can
classify that kind of thing
thank you
okay I have a question for you since 60
percent of the state's electricity is
used by industrial commercial or
institutional entities
isn't this wouldn't this be a massive
expansion of the net metering program
if the assumption is 100 would take this
up then yes I don't believe that's going
to be the uptake on it you're going to
see your your significant manufacturers
I think do this so again you could see
um you know again a CNC shops or what
I'm thinking about these small
high energy consumption due to the
amount of electricity they consume for
their machines where they get offset
that load by
um
by by putting solar up but I wouldn't
expect
um a commercial entity like a small
technology company
wouldn't necessarily need it because
they're just powering their local
computers and it'd be a very small scale
if anything which they could do now
so my follow-up question would be since
the vder studied recently completed
you're gonna have to tell me what that
is because I have no idea what that is
that's the value of distributed energy
resources study thank you that was done
for the POC and the doe indicated that
there is cost shifting from net metering
to non-net metering customers maybe a
small amount because of the low
penetration of uh
distributed energy resources at the
moment but other studies show that as
that percentage grows so does the cost
shift
does it trouble you that a massive
increase in net metering would have a
negative impact therefore on rate pairs
so thank you for the question having not
read that study I do know there was a
study that said there was a small
incremental possible cost shift that
that occurred but again I I guess
as the as the one that sponsored Senate
Bill 109 that allowed it for the net
metering for our municipalities and
towns we haven't seen a large uptake of
that of that um uh law that was passed
two years ago
um so I I don't know that you're going
to see a massive uptake I what I do
think is that the people that have
extremely high energy consumption uh in
our manufacturing will take advantage of
this again I'll remind you that it's not
to the ex not to excess so there will
also be an offset if they end up
producing 125 percent of their annual
consumption that 25 will be dumped onto
the Grid at the wholesale rate which is
the same rate that would be
um charged if they were buying it from
anywhere else
any additional questions for the bill
sponsor
representative McGee ask a question
you're going to have
representative Mickey I can't see it
when you're just short
nice to see you again
um
so the point of the bill is to help
businesses lower costs right and we had
an increase in costs that the spike uh
last year that continues for many many
people and certainly businesses are
feeling that higher so I really
appreciate the bill can you say a little
bit more about lines 18 and 19 and how
it distinguishes this bill
um but for the concerns of you know cost
shifting if they're uh in no instance
shall the electric generating facility
exceed 100 of the industrial host's
average electric consumption over the
past 12 months so what you're saying is
lower your bills by producing energy
that you're going to consume that you
know you're going to consume you're not
going to be
absolutely the whole idea here is scale
right so if I'm only consuming 1.5
megawatts I want to throw a 1.5 megawatt
array up I don't want to throw a two up
because I'll exceed the capacity I may
build a build one that has the ability
to grow as my business grows and so I
could add on to it but the goal here is
not to create a revenue generation a
goal is offset and one thing I'll remind
you is that every one of our businesses
that will
um
that will potentially take a available a
veil of this will also end up paying
more in business and profit sex because
they don't have the operating costs
anymore because they've offset their
electricity costs with with the
electricity generation so that number
goes to their profit line or to their
wages to be able to hire more employees
so again
this by Saving not only by saving the uh
the cons the business at Cost you've
actually potentially increased the prop
business profits because that money will
be dumped into the profits there's no
operating costs associated with it or
they'll use it to hire more employees
which will then go to the business
Enterprise tax so again by lowering
helping businesses compete they can grow
and by helping
um offset operational costs like this
you will shift some revenue for some uh
revenue of the business over to the
profit side and what follow-up follow-up
um and my follow-up would be along the
lines of a point that was made earlier
which is that it then becomes a business
decision right everybody's not going to
do this absolutely I again I agree not
everybody's going to throw up a five
Mega but they have the option but they
have the choice to do that which is what
I think we believe in is having giving
businesses the choice on their side
whether or not they do or don't want to
do something we put one cap on here that
says you can generate more than 100
that's the one decision we took away
from them as you get generate 150
percent of your capacity and make
revenue from this but you can generate
up to 100 and offset your electric load
thank you that's clear
additional questions from the committee
seeing none I want to thank you for
introducing this legislation and I am
now going to suspend
this public hearing at 12
07 we will resume this public hearing
after the resumed public hearings on
Senate Bill 68 and Senate Bill 69
both of those bills will be heard uh in
committee with a resumption of public
hearings starting at one o'clock this
afternoon 1 pm
we will break for lunch now
and be back here at one o'clock see you
then
thank you
warning warning this meeting will begin
in one minute
okay welcome back everyone time to
resume the public hearing on House Bill
68 we have nine pink cards left to go
and the first person I will call on is
Paul
Pence pendant or Pence it of Barrington
Mr pancit
okay we'll move on next I'll call on Dan
weeks of Nash excuse me Nashua
not here
next is Louis grondin of Lee New
Hampshire
nope okay next is
Kathleen bigford of
Bradford New Hampshire
good afternoon welcome to sdne the floor
is yours
thank you
this is an adventure for me
um like I said I'm Kathleen Bigfoot I'm
from Bradford New Hampshire I'm an
initiator and a member of the Bradford
energy committee and I thank you very
much for this opportunity to speak with
you today in support of SB 68.
I along with the members of The Bradford
energy committee wholeheartedly support
SB 68 and hope that the committee will
vote to pass it
we applaud the New Hampshire
legislature's forward-thinking strategy
to bring the benefit of net metering to
New Hampshire's small municipalities
there's a an aspect of this strategy
that I would like to highlight it is
slightly tangential and I understand
that
and this is that in the area surrounding
Bradford New Hampshire electricity
distribution from a renewable energy
site is limited by the existing
infrastructure to 100 kilowatts
this means that even if a municipality
could raise the money to attract an
investor to build a one to five megawatt
solar farm
all but 100 kilowatts would be would
need to be used on site because that is
the amount of electricity the grid will
accept
we have researched many possibilities
for placing a solar farm in Bradford and
are coming to the conclusion that
without distribution infrastructure that
has much larger capacity we will need to
find other ways to provide renewable
energy to the town of residence to the
town of Bradford its residents and
Beyond
please vote
ought to pass on SB 68 so that at the
very least it can help raise awareness
that New Hampshire's electric grid needs
to be expanded in rural areas to
accommodate renewable energy generation
thank you
thank you any questions for
representative Corman has a question yes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so am I to understand
so well you said the electric
distribution around Bradford is limited
by infrastructure to 100 kilowatts is
that thank you for asking that's correct
yeah so
does that is that a limitation of how
much can get into Bradford what exactly
what does that mean that's a limitation
of how much can come off of a generation
and that's how much can go into the grid
okay at that point and many points
around there okay thank you
now I believe that an interconnection
study should someone propose to to put
new generation on the grid an
interconnection study would be done and
it would discover that the circuit on
which the generation facility was going
to be installed needed to be upgraded
and it would
indicate or or would figure out how much
that would cost and then the generator
would have the option of
making that infrastructure upgrade in
order to interconnect
uh that's been part of our study
and uh the expense of that uh is
prohibitive at the moment
okay
thank you further questions
seeing none we'll move on thank you
thank you for being here to testify
sorry to keep you waiting so long
you can thank our friends in the senate
for that
next up is Patrick
Cheatham of Londonderry
okay next step is natural Grays of the
New Hampshire Municipal Association
thank you Mr chair Nate craze from the
municipal Association we do support this
legislation has already been stated in
testimony today this is a
a simple bill that is most or I guess
half of another bill that this committee
has already heard
so I won't reiterate things that you've
already heard today I'm certainly not a
technical expert so I'd ask you ask
other people those questions
um realistically we support this
legislation because
you've already heard a couple concrete
examples of municipalities that have
looked at projects unfortunately the
project the best site for the project
would be across a political boundary not
a utility boundary and so we believe
that this legislation will help resolve
that that conflict and allow
municipalities to better collaborate on
these types of projects I'm happy to
take any questions the committee may
have questions from the committee
representative Bernardi has a question
thank you Mr chair about how many uh
facilities or or potential placements
like that are you aware of
so I think there's probably about a
handful of projects that have been uh
explored at the moment I don't have an
exact number because I'm not in the
industry I do know that the um the
Plainfield Cornish one was one example
that's come to our attention uh over the
past couple of years because that's
something that that our members have
brought to us and I believe there are a
couple others in
um other areas of the state where you
have a similar situation that the
um utility boundaries don't mirror the
municipal boundaries and there's areas
of the municipality that
really there's no other development that
would be suitable other than some sort
of energy generation facility
see no further questions I want to thank
you for your testimony here this
afternoon thank you next I'll call on
Sam Evans Brown of clean energy New
Hampshire
good afternoon Sam
foreign
for the record Sam Evans Brown the
executive director of clean energy New
Hampshire so I've I've uh handed uh
handed in one well two two documents one
is is clean energy New Hampshire's
testimony the second is a letter that is
signed by over a hundred members of
local energy committees as well as
Municipal officials
um who have uh signed on in support of
this piece of legislation
um I think there's a great deal of of
hope that that uh when with the passage
of House Bill 315 that initially
expanded the net metering program up to
five megawatts back in 2021 that there
would be a great deal of opportunity for
municipal officials to start to lower
the energy bills uh that their taxpayers
have to have to pay and unfortunately I
think what we've seen in the past two
years is that a lot of those hopes have
been dashed by this very issue that
we're that we're considering amending
today in in statute
um I can tell you that uh
I hear from solar developers regularly
who are attempting to develop sites and
what they find is that not only are they
they struggling to find
um sites that that are matched with load
but also that they're the
interconnection costs have been rising
dramatically over the past two years and
that those are um there's a number of
reasons for that they're the
inflationary pressures that have been
impacting the rest of the economy
generally but also uh the the utilities
are changing their interconnection
requirements and and requiring more
infrastructure for for connecting these
types of facilities onto the
distribution grid and so what that means
is that
if you have a small town that uh that by
itself between its Municipal meters at
its wastewater treatment plants and its
schools and whatever else is within the
boundaries of that Municipal territory
has enough load for say a one or two
megawatt array
um they they start down the road they
identify a good site with a developer
the developer submits a request for an
interconnection study and then they get
the price tag for what that study is
going to is going to cost and what they
realize is they have a project that will
not pencil unless they can grow it and
and spread those fixed costs of that
infrastructure interconnect over more
production from from a larger array
um and and I think that uh this this
bill uh what are the were the uh house
and the governor
um consider it worthy of Passage and
signing would would really unlock the
opportunities that that many of these
towns were hoping that they would see
under house bill 315 from 2021 which was
again passed on a bipartisan basis and
signed by the governor it would allow
smaller towns to to do what some larger
communities already have done which is
to to achieve that economy of scale that
comes when you when you uh take a take a
site that already is a good site
um but maybe has uh not not enough again
not enough
not enough scale to really drive down
the cost of that kilowatt hour
um so uh additionally I'd point out that
there are
with the passage of House Bill 315 back
in 2021 there are at least two dozen
um companies that are attempting to
develop these projects as we speak many
of them have become clean energy New
Hampshire members trying to understand
the political landscape and and across
the board what I've heard is that unless
this Municipal boundary issue is sorted
out many towns will will likely not be
able to develop their resources and and
achieve some lower cost energy and can
you know the resulting Bill savings that
result from that so
happy to take any questions sort of sort
of Meandering testimony there but I was
trying to hit on some of the points that
I had heard
thank you appreciate you being here to
talk to US Representative McGee has a
question
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
Mr Evans Brown for taking my question
um
when you talk about sort of uptakers
that are looking for you know to be to
participate I know in my town meeting
um we just voted to move forward on
looking into Community power so we
agreed to at least look at that so I
guess my question is you said you had a
hundred members of various energy
organizations around the State sign on
oh what is the input coming into clean
energy New Hampshire about how many
people are actually looking to lower
their costs because that was our
motivation in our town meeting everyone
is trying to figure out how to lower
costs from you people that are running
municipalities as well as you know
the folks who are voting at the meetings
are also saying you know full-throatedly
if this will lower our costs
yeah it's responsive yeah no that's
exactly right I mean I mean universally
what we're clean energy New Hampshire be
uh we get a lot of these inquiries
because people don't necessarily
understand what we do so so we we get uh
we we become sort of the funnel for a
lot of uh these questions and we tend to
try to push them off to the the entities
that are best suited to serve them but
but you're you're not wrong that our our
sort of General access inbox has just
been flooded with inquiries from from
individuals from municipalities from
businesses that are all trying to to
reduce their energy costs
um and and on the municipal front um I
know that there are there are dozens of
communities that have identified good
sites for Community scale uh solar
arrays for instance instance
um and have have put those out to bid
and um and when the numbers come in they
find that that you know until until you
are able to build a bigger project
spread out those fixed costs over more
production a lot of these communities
scale projects don't pencil under under
our current policy structure
what questions for Mr Brown
representative Reynolds
thank you Mr chairman Sam isn't it
best described isn't it true that under
current law
there is generally speaking an inverse
and and a perverse relationship
between the requirement that
a host of Municipal group metering
and all the group members be within the
same
municipality
and
the scale of the community the load that
is needed to get to
the scale of of a
of of a facility that is economic is
that I mean so I think what you're
asking and and maybe maybe you can
correct me if I'm off off base here as
communities grow their land starts to be
taken up but you know suitable land for
building a site and starts to be taken
up by more and more uses and you have
fewer good sites but you've got more
more need right so there's a mismatch
there's a mismatch between communities
that have enough load versus communities
that have an abundance of good sites and
yes absolutely I think that's the case
thank you
additional questions
seeing none I'll ask a question
Mr Brown Can you help me understand
if if you were here earlier today this
morning you heard me mention that over
the weekend I was reading the revision
energy contract with the county of
Rockingham to install a five megawatt
solar array at the County Complex that's
going to be built over the next two
years and the price tag on that array
was 10 million dollars
and
according to the contract
and so my question for you is
how long would it take to for the
taxpayers at Rockingham County to
realize a return on that investment
without having it in front of me I would
I would hesitate to uh to to answer that
question but what I would say is that
The Upfront Capital costs uh are perhaps
not the best metric to answer that
question the real question is what is
the per kilowatt hour or per megawatt
hour cost of the electricity that it's
going to be generated and and uh and
what is the the PPA structure or or the
you know the structure through which the
Rockingham County Complex is buying that
electricity and so uh really the answer
to that question is is the elect is the
production cost effective and uh you
know I'm sure I could try I'm not a math
guy I I could try to Crunch the numbers
if if I knew the capacity of the array
and uh and could make some assumptions
about its production to try to guess
what the per kilowatt hour number would
be but um but that's the real you know
electricity is a commodity right it's
like it's like ground beef uh and and
when you're when you're purchase seeing
your ground beef you want to shop with
the right number in mind uh with ground
beef it's price per pound with
electricity as dollars per kilowatt hour
so the the capital cost is really
um you know it obviously drives that
number but it's not the right one to
look at
so help me understand this
we're going to ignore the capital cost
which by my calculations comes out to
about a dollar and 69 cents per kilowatt
hour
uh we're going to ignore that and just
for focus on
the
cost of the electricity
that would be avoided
by taking this
arrays electricity and using it within
the County Complex is that what you said
uh well so I'd want again I want to know
actually what the the cost per kilowatt
hour that the county is is planning to
pay is and I would not I would not base
it on on calculations done sitting at a
hearing room table I'd want to know what
the developer put into their PPA because
they're all in structure is going to
look a lot different than just
multiplying the you know the the our
whatever assumptions you baked into on
your phone there right so so that
includes uh the fact that there are
federal tax incentives as well as the
ability to sell renewable energy credits
both of which could be applied as
discounts to the to the PPA that that is
signed on to at Rockingham
um so so those make a big difference but
also uh 16 16 just sounds uh very high
for a per kilowatt hour price for a
utility scale solar array today you know
Maine when they issued their their
request for proposals for utility scale
solar got numbers as low was three cents
per kilowatt hour
that
excuse me that included the capital cost
yes yeah
interesting
well we haven't seen the PPA yet all
we've seen is the contract to build the
array
um
the county is paying for it so the
county will own it once it's built
which probably is an advantage to the
county I was going to say if you own it
that's the that's the best way to
capture all the benefits is to own the
own the facility yourself okay questions
on the financing cost at that point as I
learned more about the terms of the PPA
when they become available we'll uh
we'll have further discussions on this
so thank you
any further questions for the museum
Evans Brown of clean energy New
Hampshire seeing none I'll thank you and
we'll move along here
next I'll call on Joellen Courtney of
infield New Hampshire
welcome Ms Courtney
thanks for making the long trip over
from Enfield sure my name is Joellen
Courtney and I'm chair of the Enfield
energy committee
and I would like to
encourage you to support this bill and
it would benefit the Mascoma Valley
Regional School District which is
comprised of
Canaan Enfield Grafton Dorchester and
orange
very small communities
and so this Regional School District
could benefit by this
okay thank you very much are there any
questions for Miss Courtney
representative Corman who I think lives
in that area has a question thank you Mr
chairman yes Ms Courtney I live in
Lebanon I frequently bicycle into
Enfield in Canaan and I go right by the
high school on the rail trail so I'm
just wondering can you elaborate a
little bit more on how this would
benefit the the district
I see potential for the future I don't
see that there's anything on the books
right now
um
but looking forward I see that that
whole area Grafton
Dorchester and orange there's a lot of
open space there and there's be
potential for putting up a solar farm
you know
representative closure has a question
thank you chair thank you Miss Courtney
as a former residence of Grafton and
Grafton County
um did you look at our low-income
families out there in you know where
they are is this going to have a
positive effect for those Property
Owners thank you I would expect so sir
um again there's nothing on the books
there's nothing planned but I just see
this as a potential and that's why I
would really encourage you to vote for
it
any additional questions for Ms Courtney
see none I want to thank you for being
here
thanks for making the long drive
next we'll call on Charles George of
Rollinsford New Hampshire
please turn on your mic
the button down below thank you thank
you Mr chairman and representatives on
the committee
um I'm a lifelong resident of New
Hampshire 40 years in Rollinsford
a former business owner retired now
and uh just started to take an interest
in uh
local
government a few years ago I'm on the
budget Committee in Rollinsford
and I have seen the small small town
works and operation
and this bill I really feel would
help us
in the small communities
lower our energy costs
it seems that this year we've seen a
tremendous jump like everyone has and
going forward it's really difficult to
estimate
how long
we're going to be climbing with energy
costs
we in Rollins for just this past fall
actually through the budget committee
petitioned the select board
to
make a energy commission to look at
energy
usage in town and ways to conserve and
improve our position with energy
in fact
the Rollinsford energy commission is
mostly made up of budget committee
members who are all interested in
capping or lowering this cost
um
we're newcomers to the solar idea
although personally I have some
experience I put solar panels on my
business
and I have solar panels on my home and I
found
investment to be very worthwhile
and I thought
if there's a way for the municipality to
be able to take advantage of some of
these benefits
and help the taxpayers and keep our tax
base
costs down this would be
a project we want to get behind and we
did some
research in the area and we do have the
resource and attractive land that
we think would be a good
location for a solar field it's close to
transmission power lines it's pretty
much undevelopable
in any other respect
and um as we looked into it we were
discouraged by the fact that we would
have to have
something in the scale of five megawatts
for it to be economically feasible and
that was
um
a cost prohibitive
ceiling for us with the limited usage
for the town I mean we have our schools
we have our municipal buildings
the sewer and water treatment plant
but we couldn't justify
a solar field of that magnitude alone
this bill would enable us to Parlay our
resource with other communities
and take advantage of clean energy
reduce the cost for taxpayers and
um and that's the reason why we're here
three of us from Rollinsford
to make sure that the legislature knows
that the small communities need a break
in order to crack this energy nut I
don't think it's a Panacea
for all of our problems but we must take
advantage of every opportunity and and
it seems to me that New Hampshire has
been dragging their feet in
incentivizing
smaller communities
from
um from the process of solving our
energy crunch so I'd encourage
the committee
um and the house to support this bill
and give
our small communities a voice and an
opportunity in solving our energy
problems
um
I appreciate the time that I had to come
before you unaccustomed as I am I'm
showing up for hearings I've learned a
lot and I have a lot of Hope and Faith
that the house will understand the
plight of the small communities that
want to keep taxpayers happy and
taxpayers in town and
and this this bill I think
isn't a Panacea but it will certainly
help
muster
community relations we've already had
some conversations with uh
other communities and we're expecting to
be able to um
see what comes out of Concord
for encouragement so please make it
happen for us thank you for your time
thank you well we appreciate you being
here because you're giving us the
opportunity to
learn from you and your experiences
now you said earlier that you had bought
a solar system for your business and
also one for your home is that true
that's correct that's correct I put uh
solar panels on my business
um
seven years ago
um maybe closer to eight now
um
the system paid for itself in less than
four years
and currently
the state benefits
from
um
my
project in that uh
I leased this the space to the state and
they have a reduced Energy bill as a
result of those panels that are on the
building
I've retired I developed my building
and the Tenant gets the benefit
of the electrical savings now on on that
building and it's uh it's a small system
it's uh
um 55 megawatt system which is
considered a small system in the scale
of
the systems you're talking about here
but it it definitely makes a huge dent
in the utility bill it did for me as a
business owner and I actually
um
used less energy than I produced
and um
I was entitled to
sell the energy back to the
to eversource and of course
that's a losing proposition because they
pay you a wholesale
figure versus uh what you're paying but
I understood that I was able and this is
what I don't understand about our law
right now I understood I was able
to make a a net metering group
and sell that energy to customers
that was excess
I never followed up on that Prospect but
I don't understand why
small communities shouldn't be able to
do the same thing
and I know there's a lot more to the
workings than I understand I I overheard
the department of Energy's concerns
about this bill I don't understand
um
the politics behind it but the common
sense behind it is definitely there
from my experience
so you said that
uh
the system that you installed on your
business and your house or your home
saved you a lot of money yes
but then you also said that when your
energy committee looked at uh
a town solar system of five megawatts it
was not
well financially or economically
feasible
so my question would be if it was
feasible for your in your business and
for you personally
why can't you find a put together a
system that's feasible economically for
the town if it saves the town lots of
money
well we could
with this bill okay we can
team up with other communities
and meet the five megawatt which is this
you know three to five is The Sweet Spot
for it on a much smaller scale
I don't think it would be
economically feasible
to build a solar field to just
accommodate
what energy Rollinsford uses alone
but if we were able to Parlay
economically feasible size lot a
feasible size solar field with other
communities
we would reap the benefit they would
reap the benefit and we would be able to
lower our energy costs
through a group effort and that's the
big thing sure we could apply for a
solar array for town hall or the school
or whatever else have you
and that
in it in and of itself represents a cost
that you know we would have to try to
reclaim
on an individual basis with uh all of
the other complexities that go along
with it but by having one project that
we could further fan out and uh find
enough uh demand
for and spread the cost out we feel we
could
save the taxpayers money
and make it feasible and you know
that's all we're asking for is that
you'll look at a way to to make us get
beyond the town of Rollins in order to
be able to take advantage of
some of the incentives that are out
there
so what evidence did your town energy
committee find that this so-called three
to five megawatts Sweet Spot exists and
it did that what kind of cost reductions
did that supposed Sweet Spot provide
we haven't done enough research on what
that size was because that was Out Of
Reach
with the current legislation when we
first were formed we're still trying
we're still learning and trying to find
out
what we could actually end up saving but
if it's any comparison to what I've
found from my experience
I pay
um
very little
back to eversource
on my home
because I have solar panels
I virtually have just the transmission
costs most months other than
I would say December and January I think
that the same kind of savings could be
passed on to taxpayers
with participation in a solar field
and I don't know the actual numbers
we're in our infancy we just started
this commission last fall and we've been
looking at always uh
to find a cap on our energy costs we
just are under currently entertaining a
contract
um like many communities in the area to
convert our Municipal lights
to LED and uh
we're just looking for ways to cap our
energy costs reduce the taxpayers burden
when it comes to energy and I just think
that this bill
is a baby step towards that direction
and that's that's why we're here to make
sure the house knows
well that we're behind it in small
communities like us are behind it
representative Bernardi has a question
okay thank you chairman did you uh just
evaluate the costs and the benefits of
putting up something for the town hall
or for the school or whatever just of
the appropriate size for those
facilities
we have not gotten the cost on that
because
the suitability
and the space is not there
in order to ask for a quote town hall is
a very small
building very small area
um
the school the orientation is not such
that the building itself would support
a solar array that would uh be
necessary for reducing that cost
um
and basically you know the same is true
for uh Waste Water treatment I mean it's
shaded
considerably by trees
and you the orientation
has to be favorable for a solar field to
work and that's not the case in our
our particular example anyway and I I
don't think we're unique
in that lots of small towns have a
number of small buildings and they're
not in the smaller towns not necessarily
A cleared area
for solar to be with viable possibility
so
you know once again I say we do have
land that would be favorable
but
um we would need
to be able to Parlay
the effort in order to be able to make
it feasible we certainly couldn't
come up with the kind of money that
Rockingham County is suggesting they're
they're going to spend
um but
together whatever the cost is we think
we could make sense to the public so so
on that land that you do have available
could you put up a facility size to
handle the water treatment plant the
school in the town hall
definitely but I don't know what the
transmission
cost would be and um
that's something that I guess is would
would require more research going down
but if you're in for Penny you ought to
be in for a pound I mean why shouldn't
we be able to uh to get a bigger scale
of economy than than just support
um basically be able to afford or
support a solar array I mean we're
talking probably
[Music]
um
you know a much smaller array than what
the economy of scale would would require
I understand thank you thank you
representative partial has a question
yes thank you chair and thank you for
Testimony today
um
the situation that's described with your
town hall and with your school and with
your Wastewater Plant could I see that
as an analogy of the problem that all
these small towns are having facing the
economy of scale that makes uh anything
less than hitting that sweet spot of
three to five megawatts
financially unfeasible
I can't speak to that because I haven't
uh
I don't know what
the size of other communities are or
what their budget what their own energy
budgets are so I really can't speak to
that I just know from Rollinsford
standpoint okay it
um would make sense to be able to
get together with other communities
close by
um
our resource is is there and we'd like
to be able to
use our resource
and help those communities that might
not have the availability
of land that we do and all of us work
towards a common goal I I don't know I
haven't spoken with enough of other
communities to know what their demands
are or I know some have successfully put
solar arrays on school in Barrington
and um
and other Municipal facilities
um I'm aware of the Brentford Brentwood
I think did a solar field that
accommodated there
municipalities needs
but I don't have enough
um information to know
the ins and outs of how they stack up to
Rollinsford
thank you yep
okay thank you sir we appreciate you
being here today
or pink cards left
and I have called on all these people
before but I'm going to go through the
cards again in case some people walked
in who weren't here when I called on
them before is Paul
pen sit of Barrington here
oh I'm sorry to hear that could you
pronounce your last name for me I panish
panich like Spanish without the S oh
okay okay well thank you sorry to
mispronounce it no and thank you for the
opportunity to address you today
um I'm chair of the Barrington energy
committee I am not speaking on their
behalf due to the short notice I was
unable to get a consensus of the
committee on what we would how we would
address this here so I'm speaking on my
own and I'm speaking in favor of Senate
bill 68.
um it represents what seems to be to be
a minor legislative addition to the
previously passed House Bill 315 and it
would level level the field for smaller
towns to gain efficiencies of scale
reduce costs for shelled Municipal solar
installations
which are already available to larger
cities and towns that are taking
advantage of that now I'm sorry if I'm
covering area we've already been over
there are other reasons in addition to
the economy of scale that could benefit
some towns were this option to be
available to cite joint installation
with other municipalities one of these
is the availability of sighting for
medium scale solar installations such as
these
most towns have a decentralized
infrastructure it is generally most
Advantage advantageous to implement
on-site behind the meter systems for
direct utilization of power that's
generated however it's not always
practical to to do this for any number
of reasons some of those would be space
exposure structural building issues on
buildings which were not designed to
support arrays on the roofs so this can
make a centralized generation facility
to offset Municipal usage an attractive
option however the availability of sites
can be a significant problem
one of the sighting concerns which we've
run into in Barrington is the concern of
residents that such a facility would
negatively affect their property values
for those in the immediate vicinity of
the solar field
recent Studies have shown sighting of
solar solar installations in areas that
have been cleared by fallow areas such
as abandoned or played out gravel pits
landfields Brownfield sites if they
happen to be available do not negatively
affect property values for properties in
the immediate vicinity of the array
not all towns have such sites available
that also are near the power
infrastructure necessary for the power
of distribution from that site
to build out that power line
infrastructure it can represent a
significant additional cost and can make
the feasibility of this impractical
the ability to jointly develop sites
which are already well situated with
regards to the power infrastructure and
site conditions could be a significant
Aid to helping municipals gain the
economies of scale to reduce the cost of
Municipal Power for their residents and
in this sense going to some of your
questions to the previous speaker
optimization is always an issue we're
always trying to come there there's
always a variety of options available
it's our job to optimize the selections
that we're making and and what we're
presenting to our residents as
possibilities and generally what we're
looking at is how to reduce costs to the
greatest extent possible
um
but perhaps the most convincing reason
for fast passing sb68 in my mind is that
there's really doesn't seem to be any
reason not to do so why should the
Regulatory Agencies have an arbitrary
rule in place serves no purpose other
than to increase the cost of power to
smaller municipalities in their
residence
if the utilities don't have the
necessary capabilities in place to allow
for these facilities and I'm saying that
when I'm when I'm saying that I'm
thinking in an automated fashion
it's because it's been profitable for
them to ignore the need for modernizing
their metering and billing
infrastructures
in the past due the type of power
generation commonly available this
didn't result in significant cost to
Consumers
but this says this hasn't been the case
for some time now now that the cost of
additional renewable generation has
become the lowest cost option available
this situation has changed it's
essential that utilities build out the
capabilities necessary to support such
shared infrastructure along with other
types of disaggregation such as
Community power thank you
thank you appreciate you being here to
give us your perspective representative
partial has a question for you
thank you chair and easy question is
your testimony available did you mail it
to the committee I did not I'd be glad
to give this as part of the record it
would be a good read thank you so much
nope thank you
see no additional questions I'll thank
you again for being here and call next
on Dan weeks of Nashua
okay next is Louis grondin of Lee
Lou grondin of Lee I'm on the Lee energy
committee and also uh I'm the chairman
of the Lee energy committee and also the
chairman of the Lee Community power
committee
and um
the the main purpose
one of our main goals in in the
committee is to save
money to the town on energy issues
whether it's heating power and that's
what that's what we spend most of our
time on
we've just had a warrant article on
community power
and the main goal of that was to save
save money for our residents and that
passed 5 18 4 and 85 against so I can I
can say that
people in our town are very focused on
saving money
saving money for the town saving money
for themselves and everybody knows we're
one of the states that have the highest
energy costs in the country so that's
that's very important
um
we're surrounded by six towns we've got
Barrington Madbury
Durham
New Market
Epping
and Nottingham
so
um between those six towns and us
um that's a that's a big load there's a
lot of schools there's a lot of town
buildings and
um I think it would definitely be
worth it to form a community of towns to
lower the costs and everyone knows that
economies of scales
a scale is very important in lowering
costs so I haven't we're having our
meeting tomorrow morning so I haven't
actually I don't actually hit
um
I can't actually say the committee
itself is
voted to support this but I I can
guarantee you they would and uh so I'm
just asking for the com the committee to
support this it makes sense and it's
like a Chicken and the Egg situation you
gotta have one first before you can have
the other and so it has to start
somewhere
this is where it has to start
there's no reason why the larger towns
should be able to get the economies of
scale and the smaller ones don't so
um I just wanted to keep that short
not repeat what everybody else has said
so
well thank you questions from the
committee representative munz has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for for coming in in any of the work
that you have done on the energy
committee and and in any discussions
that you may have had with your local
utility has
has the problems of interconnection does
that come up as an issue we have a big
problem in in Lee yeah there's very very
little interest infrastructure for
there's basically no infrastructure for
a large arrays in Lee I can I can tell
you that
follow-up follow-up so again in in those
if to the extent you've had a follow-up
conversation with the utility I mean if
I haven't has there been a discussion
about you know what kind of improvements
might need to be made before you could
actually Implement an array I haven't
had any discuss we haven't had any
discussions with the utilities uh but
I've had
one person in town was approached by a
company who wanted to put a 10 Meg array
on his property unfortunately the the
closest uh
okay
connection to it was a mile and a half
and there was there was a
it fell through because of the cost of
of
the infrastructure
to the convenient power
thank you
okay so you know further questions I
thank you for being here to testify and
I call finally last testifier on this
bill
is Patrick Cheatham of Londonderry
here okay
Mr Cheatham is apparently not here so
that completes our testimony on Senate
bill
SB 68
so we'll close the public hearing on
Senate Bill 68 and resume the public
hearing on Senate Bill 69 we have two
pink cards for that one and so I'll call
First on Mr Griffin Roberge from the
Department of energy to give us the
Department's view of this legislation
uh thank you Mr chairman uh members of
the committee uh again for the record
Griffin Roberge New Hampshire Department
of energy
um department is opposed to Senate Bill
69 as amended by the Senate
um running through the bill quite
briefly
um
Senate Bill 69
um creates an exception for a municipal
host from the current one megawatt net
metering cap
under the definition of customer
generator
um section two Define creates the
definition of a non-profit host which is
very closely mirrors the municipal host
definition
um total Peak generating capacity of
greater than one less than five
megawatts used to offset uh electricity
requirements for a group of non-profits
as long as all the nonprofits are in the
same service utility much like a
municipal host non-profit host can be
publicly or privately owned and then
um
the definition of a non-profit under
that statute is defined on lines 9 to
12.
and then section three goes further and
adds an additional statutory exemption
that permits non-profits who may already
be customer generators themselves uh to
take part in these uh Municipal host
Arrangements
um holistically the the bill essentially
creates a group host mechanism that goes
above the one the current one megawatt
cap for certain non-profits and emulates
really the statutory model that exists
for municipal hosts
department does oppose this bill for
several reasons as uh previously
mentioned the department does oppose any
changes to the state's net metering
statute at this time while the puc's
docket de 22060 is currently underway
and uh as I've previously mentioned that
docket will consider changes to the
current net metering tariff structure
including compensation for customer
generators we would suggest laying that
that process play out before making any
sizable changes to net metering statutes
additionally regarding the bill
um we did have some technical uh
concerns there is a lack of clarity
around some of the entities listed as a
non-profit definition I think some of
the committee members asked some
questions about that previously
on line 20 it indicates that a
non-profit means any Community or
Technical College colleges and
universities
hospitals as defined in another area
statute housing authorities bona fide
religious organizations and the peas
Development Authority a couple of the
concerns that we had is could for-profit
colleges and universities potentially
take advantage of this because that's
not exactly spelled out so could a
for-profit technically be a non-profit
under this statute what does a bona fide
religious organization mean those are
just
some of the questions that we had
regarding that definition
additionally and we're going to talk
about this shortly but in Senate Bill 79
the Senate did not address potential
conflicts between the two bills both of
them seek to do as section 2 and this
bill identifies as create a new
paragraph 2G
if both were to pass and become law both
uh again proposed creating that
paragraph and if both became law one
could potentially override the other and
create significant inconsistencies in
the state's net metering statutes
so those are those are at least some of
the technical ones that you have between
two bills that you have pending before
you today other than that that really
concludes my testimony on this bill
thank you representative Thomas has a
question for you thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question I'm
just curious since um this seems to be a
puc DACA day
um on several bills do you have any idea
if any of what these bills that we've
discussed today have has any of that
subject matter come up during the docket
that you're aware of I mean would they
consider any of the stuff here I'd just
like to know what what they're
discussing since they've been at it for
a while sure thank you for the question
so I would just know that the docket
really opened up this new one 22060
opened up late last year and they're
still in the in the I would respectfully
submit the early stages of that docket
um regarding
um legislation you know I can I can
point to the puc's order to open up the
docket is that they pointed to Senate
Bill 261 from last year and House Bill
1599 as you know part of the reason or
the Genesis to open that docket
um we would respectfully submit letting
that docket play out in its entirety
before making further substantive
changes to New Hampshire's net metering
statutes
additional questions representative
McGee has a question thank you Mr
chairman and good to see you again Mr
Robert I hope you enjoyed your lunch
um
well I have a question on what you just
said about the docket
um on tariff setting being related to
whether we
adopt any of these or update our net
metering statutes and I guess the
question that I have is
the Tariff setting piece is really just
what the value of net metering is right
so that can change and go up and down
and that but that's separate and
distinct from whether or not we allow
people to do net metering so the changes
in the economic picture
might happen for those individuals
who've already invested or who are
planning to invest
but I I don't understand what the
connection is to saying that we should
hold up legislation in terms of
responding to the people that just left
here testifying that they're really
trying to you know trying to lower their
their bills no and I get that thank you
very much for the question so uh to
start off I would suggest is that the
docket is looking at potential changes
to the alternative net metering tariff
that tariff applies to anything whether
or not you're just a normal individual
homeowner you know as a customer
generator or whether or not you want to
you know want to be a non-profit host or
something to that effect
um and again another element of that
docket is reviewing the cost shifting
impacts from
um the current mechanism that's in play
I think we would respectfully submit
just let everything kind of remain
static the way it is while the puc fully
adjudicates these issues rather than
making substantive changes to netmiring
statutes where you might have an
industrial hosted net a non-profit host
an expansion of the current Municipal
host statute we would encourage you know
an economic review through that puc
adjudicative process before making
substantive changes to net viewing
statute at this time
so clarification you need a follow-up
representative yes please okay go ahead
so the objection is a concern for cost
shifting again yes I mean again that is
that is one of the things that the puc
will be looking at in its adjudicative
proceeding you know to the extent cost
shifting is occurring and and the vder
study it did identify that there is you
know at this point a one percent cost
shift we would submit letting that
process play out to fully adjudicate
these issues and
not exacerbate any potential cost shift
that's that's currently that's currently
in existence
okay representative munz asked a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for uh being here again
um as someone who spent a good part of
the morning asking questions about
definitions welcome to the definition
dark side
um
I understand you know that the concern
you that you've shared about the you
know the kind of the economic impact of
any potential change like that this
might have
um but we we just heard from a number of
people that you know talked about some
of the technical
challenges of you know implementing this
kind of arrangement has the department
or or anybody done any kind of a
technical review to kind of understand
you know what some of those challenges
are what the landscape looks like and
start to put together a plan on how we
might want to address that sure so thank
you for the question so
um I know I know there were a number of
things said in earlier testimonies sent
Bill 68 regarding the Litany of things
like interconnection costs uh economies
of scale and that type of thing I can't
address every single one of those but I
do know that there are a number of
things actively underway or have
occurred that seek to address some of
the issues that people have in building
out these systems whether it's sizing up
interconnecting that type of thing so
for example Senate Bill 262 that was
signed into law last year created a
hosting capacity maps that electric
distribution utilities I had to post on
their website
those Maps can help identify areas where
facilities might be able to interconnect
where it's it's more easier or or there
might be need to be a significant
infrastructure upgrades you know making
sure that they're aware that might be
cost prohibitive to do so here versus
over here another element of Senate Bill
262 last year required the department of
energy to open up a proceeding on
interconnection issues that
interconnection I believe that that
opened up in December of last year the
department received written comment from
the utilities as well as various other
entities in the state such as clean
energy New Hampshire and other renewable
advocacy groups
that period closed I think end of
February I don't know the current status
of it right now but those are just at
least maybe some of the things that were
identified
um yeah I'm going to stop I feel like
I'm gambling I'm sorry follow-up
follow-up
um so is as a follow-up I mean it has
has the department taken any action to
apply for
grants from you know the federal
government under the infrastructure act
or the the inflation reduction act to
try to to try to secure funding to
address some of these concerns sure so
again thank you for the question much
like um representative McWilliams
question earlier today on the polls bill
um you know it's really dependent on
what the federal government allows for
eligible activities under those various
pots of funding
um you know I think at this time we're
largely prioritizing on those formula
grant opportunities and then staff up to
maybe go after some of the competitive
opportunities I'm not aware off the top
of my head of a specific pot of funding
that would help address interconnection
issues per se there's certainly money
out there for municipalities to build
out say renewable energy projects like
the eecbg program but
um regarding maybe some more of these
technical issues I'd have to do a deeper
dive on that
thank you for the question
so I have a question for you the fiscal
note with this bill
says that at least 65 entities
that are not currently eligible for net
metering would become eligible
under this bill
at five megawatts each that would come
out to like 325 megawatts
I believe the current installed solar
capacity in the state right now is only
about 180 megawatts so this would more
than double
uh
the amount of solar in the state
isn't that is is that the analysis that
the department came up with I and thank
you for the question I can already feel
representative Munn's queuing up a
question for me but
um was it I I would note that you know I
think we identified at least six based
on the definition of 65 I'm sorry based
on the definition of nonprofit as
identified in this bill there may be
more you know depending on how you
clarify say bona fide religious
organizations
um you know I think what we try to
outline in the fiscal note is really
just a general sense we cannot predict
the future you know I've asked around we
don't have the Oracle of Delphi camped
around somewhere in the department of
energy somewhere I can't predict how
many of these entities would take
advantage of this bill should it become
law
um but you know I
I'd say I'd say there's the there's
certainly the potential for growth of
these systems and installed capacity
what it would ultimately be that's
asking me to predict the future and
that's a little difficult I'm sorry fair
enough I won't ask you to do that
further questions for Mr Roberge
seeing none thank you oh thank you very
much and call on the last person who has
submitted a pink card for
Senate Bill 69 and that's the honorable
Lee oxenham from Plainfield welcome back
thank you very much Mr chair decided to
make a day of it huh I am and I should
have identified myself as a member of
the Plainfield energy committee
um so two points um want to support this
bill suggests that uh including
nonprofits is a great idea but mostly
interested in the the last issue that
came up in the discussion uh prompted by
representative McGee's query there's the
value of distributed energy resources
study was a key component of a previous
docket
along with the battery pilot that was
undertaken by Liberty Utilities this was
to give us real data about real
circumstances in New Hampshire having to
do with the Tariff for net metering was
there in fact cost shifting this has
been an overriding issue for the whole
entire six years I was on this committee
this study has answered the question
there is an insignificant
cost shift of roughly one percent when
you take into account the criteria
listed if you go to the dunski study
it lists many of the things which are
not included and if they were included
would shift that one percent to possibly
a 20 percent cost shift in the opposite
direction that people who have invested
have taken this incentive to put private
investment into creating renewable
energy create benefits that redown to
the entire system to the entire grid
that benefit everyone and the cost shift
is from them to the general ratepayer
representative McGee's specific question
had to do with isn't there a difference
between who is included in the net
metering tariff and what the net
metering tariff is the current docket
that has only just opened and if anybody
thinks it's going to be done in a year
I've got a bridge in Brooklyn for you
that is going to look at what should the
Tariff be
what are those advantages that are
redowned to the entire system what are
the costs to the entire system what is
the fair and Equitable reasonable tariff
that compensates people adequately and
fairly that is gives no advantages that
is the current docket that has just
opened the value of distributed energy
resources has established the base point
that we currently have if you look at
these enumerated criteria
a one percent cost shift which everyone
agrees
is agreed is a relatively insignificant
number it has been suggested by the
chair that ah but in the future it could
be different yes many things could be
different in the future however
the best we can do at hand is to use
what we have created with painstaking
care over the last six years this data
set and use this data set to come up
with a fair representation
that doesn't mean we should stop looking
at who should qualify to utilize net
metering rates which is the the bulk of
the bills today
they don't need to be held up the way we
held up things for the last six years
while we were waiting to know whether
there was a significant cost shift or
not
we know there isn't one we know that
under current circumstances there isn't
one
so I just want to be very clear that the
new docket is about setting possibly
changing the net median rate
remember we currently are operating
under an alternative net metering rate
that is an interim rate because we
didn't know if the rate originally
established which was a one-to-one was
fair and adequate compensation
so we could go back to that rate we
could continue the alternative we could
come up with an entirely new net
metering rate that is what the new
docket is about it is not about
establishing the value of solar in New
Hampshire
thank you
thank you questions for
former representative oxenham
so did I understand you to say that we
need to rely on studies
as someone who worked for 10 years at
the National Academy of Sciences as an
economic analyst yes I rely on studies
that is science that is our best way of
understanding the world we live in
okay so the study that says that as the
penetration of distributed energy
resources goes up the percentage of cost
shifting goes up is a study we should
also rely on then
I would suggest that a single study with
that conclusion needs to be looked at I
have before me the meta study by The
Institute for energy Innovation which
says that when you look at the numerous
studies that have been performed over
the last decade the preponderance them
says clearly that uh
the economic benefits of net metering
outweigh the cost to the utility and
rather than imposing a net cost net
metering in most cases a net benefit
with increasing amounts we're we're in
new ground and I would suggest that if
we get to 20 penetration 50 penetration
this will need to be uh Revisited
okay thank you questions for the former
representative
seeing none thank you thank you for
being here to testify on this bill
and since I have no more pink cards for
this bill I'm going to close the public
hearing on Senate bill
69 and now we will resume the public
79.
so we're resuming this one at 216.
and I have
three pink cards here so the first
person I'll call on is Griffin Roberge
of the Department of energy
thank you members of the committee uh
again Griffin Roberge Synergy program
manager at the department of energy
um
Department as opposed sent Bill 79 as
amended by the Senate
um going through the bill
section one of the bill
um repeals and reenacts the definition
of customer generator
um inserting a provision regarding an
industrial host on line seven
section two
further down on line 12 or I should say
14 sorry creates the definition of
industrial host and this language again
largely emulates uh kind of what we saw
with the municipal host statute and the
non-profit Bill beforehand the language
defines that host as a customer
generator of greater than one megawatt
less than five that is used to offset
the electricity requirements of a group
consisting entirely of one commercial
industrial or institutional entity with
one or more accounts provide that
they're all in the same service
territory and then a host may be either
publicly or privately owned and in no
instance shall the electricity
generating facility exceed 100 of the
industrial hosts average electric
consumption over the 12 months
um Department opposes this bill for a
number of reasons looking at the
technical language of the bill section
one as I mentioned
um
repeals and reenacts the definition of
customer generator there are really two
significant changes here is one adds the
definition or as a reference to
Industrial host on line seven but most
notably it also removes the current one
megawatt cap in the customer generator
statute entirely so hypothetically there
is no limit on net metering anymore for
customer generators aside from those a
municipal host or industrial host
Arrangements
section two also requires that the
electricity generating facility there on
lines
18 and 19
shall not exceed the industrial host
average electric consumption over the
past 12 months this is a language that
might seem a little familiar to those
who are around last year on Senate Bill
262 that this committee ultimately
removed the department again raises
concerns as we did on that bill with
what occurs if that facilities if that
customer's average electric consumption
drops over that 12-month period as I
think we're all aware
there could be things like a pandemic
that occurs that can significantly
Alters the electric consumption for
utilities who monitors that facilities
average electric consumption who does
the system become deactivated if it goes
over this threshold
um again some further Clarity there I
think would be welcomed
um
also in the industrial host uh statue
that is a little bit unclear as to what
a commercial industrial or institutional
entity is
um another point is as I raised on
Senate Bill 69 uh the Senate did not
amend either this bill or Senate Bill 69
to address conflicting language between
both bills again for again both bills
seek to create a new paragraph 2G to the
extent that these bills pass and become
law one bill again could potentially
override the other and create
significant inconsistencies in New
Hampshire's net metering statutes
and finally I do want to note that
there's really nothing in State Statute
that prevents private companies from
constructing their own generating
facilities above the current one
megawatt cap if they choose to do so
private companies would not be
compensated for their excess generation
at the current net metering tariffs but
would be compensated wholesale power
rates it remains a policy question I
it's something that you know we want to
raise it's a policy question as to
whether private entities should be
entitled to a faster rate of return on
their Investments at the expense of
non-distributed generation customers
um
regarding that that closes out my
testimony on this bill and I'm happy to
take any questions
thank you questions for Mr brobarge on
Senate bill 79.
representative McGee
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
robish thank you
um so we've been discussing several
times this morning the open docket for
review of the current existing net
metering tariff yep but if there is
um an existing tariff saying what net
metering should cost or or is valued at
let's say then why wouldn't someone who
is
producing that energy in your mind be
eligible for that
recompense in other words why should
they be making less
if they're if they're generating energy
that other people can benefit from oh no
thank you for the question so I what I
mean to say is that you know there are a
lot of arguments about increasing the
met the megawatt cap to five megawatts
there is nothing preventing entities
from doing so uh private companies from
doing so if you go above the one
megawatt cap however you will be those
entities will be reimbursed or paid back
at wholesale power rates it's not going
to be at the net metering tariff that's
currently in existence for those below
one megawatt
um I I just wanted to note that that I
don't want people getting confused is
that you know there's something
preventing these facilities uh from
going above the one megawatt cap you
just alter the level of compensation
that you get for that power that you put
back onto the grid
may I follow up of course but I think
you you're taking it back off sort of
the questions my point was what we've
been hearing from folks today is that
they're trying to figure out how to make
projects economical and I think the the
fact that people are trying to be able
to scale the projects to get those
economies of scale and also be
compensated for the scale of the energy
they're producing that I mean I think
that's what these bills are trying to
get at is to give people that
opportunity in these different slivers
and in this case in in the commercial
and Industrial sliver
um so I think
is there a question there I think what
you're what you're what I hear you
saying is that there they shouldn't be
compensated at the same rate they can do
it if they want to but isn't that the
whole point of the bill is to try and
make sure that they can sure yeah yeah
because the economies work I I agree
that's the intent of the bill but you
know I would respectfully submit there
has been discussion here today that the
uh vder study found no evidence of cost
Chef last I checked zero percent is not
one percent there there is a cost shift
um whether or not we want to expand the
cap to five megawatts and
I understand the argument to achieve
economies of scale but somebody pays
back for that uh excess generation and
whether or not
um you know policy makers want to make
it the preference that non-distributed
generation customers pay that that's
obviously a policy call but it is one
that we would respectfully submit play
out through the adjudicative process
before making sizable changes to the net
metering statute
did the vder study did not find a range
for cost shifting that started at one
percent and went as high as 2.9 percent
for industrial classes in the unitel
service territory thank you for the
question so yes I would submit that
based on the study it did vary granted
one percent is an estimate but it did
vary based on the type of type of
customer class you're looking at whether
that's residential small commercial
large commercial yes
and it also broke down based on utility
I believe as well
thank you
representative Munn says a question
um and thank you again for taking my
question
um I'm glad you caught the the the thing
about the one megawatt
um limit because I had noticed that as
well and I was just curious whether you
had had any conversation with the Bill's
sponsor to
you know shed some light on whether that
was deliberate or just an oversight sure
I I don't want to speak for the Bill's
sponsor but I do recall that uh our
policy and programs division director
Josh Elliott testified at that hearing
we were in opposition to the bill at the
hearing
um but as I recall there was an
amendment thrown out at the last second
and the committee asked I think Josh
Elliott right there in the room you know
what's your feedback
I don't think at that point where we
could digest it in a matter of seconds
and say you know this is we could give
constructive feedback but um the senate
committee at that time decided to move
along the bill as amended I couldn't
speak as to the the prime sponsors um
reasoning for that or if that was just
an oversight if that was deliberate
okay seeing no further questions we'll
move right along thank you and then I'll
ask Bill Lundgren of Stonyfield yogurt
to come speak to us about his
perspective on this legislation oops
it's not a he it's Brit I'm sorry I
misread that
sorry Brit
is that trouble
hi thanks so much for having me here
today my name is Brit Lundgren I am the
senior director of sustainability and
government Affairs at Stonyfield
Stoney field is as many of you probably
know an organic Yogurt Company based in
Londonderry New Hampshire and I'm here
to register our strong support for
Senate bill 79. this year Mark's Stoney
Field's 40th anniversary and our company
got its start here in New Hampshire many
years ago but we still are really a New
Hampshire company and we do the vast
majority of our manufacturing here in
the state and today we employ over 450
people at our Londonderry manufacturing
facility and offices
manufacturers in New Hampshire are
saddled with some of the highest
electricity rates in the nation
this problem is exacerbated by a lack of
local distributed generation resources
over our 40 years in business we have
had to rely on expensive imported
sources of energy that have put
excessive cost burden on our business
and Manufacturing operations
driven by both a desire to secure
low-cost and reliable source of
electricity and by our commitment to
sustainability Stonyfield has explored
solar energy as an option for our plant
in 2005 we installed a system that at
the time was the largest solar array in
the state of New Hampshire
well we're pleased to be able to utilize
solar energy at our plant this system
provides for less than one percent of
our energy needs
our ability to expand this solar energy
system on site is hampered by the size
of our site by the size of the building
the configuration of the rooftop and our
proximity to the Manchester Airport
we have expanded our plant several times
since we first installed this solar
power and so we have some more roof
space but even if we were to fully
utilize all of the usable roof space
that we have we still get to about five
percent of our energy needs through
on-site solar energy production and so
these limitations have led us to explore
other options for procuring electricity
from solar or other Renewable Power
installations
unfortunately the state net metering
laws currently prevent us from procuring
a sufficient amount of solar energy from
other locations in New Hampshire
our business has a goal of being 100
renewably powered by 2025. in order to
advance this goal we have had to resort
to sourcing solar electricity from a
combination of in-state resources and
purchasing renewable energy credits from
much larger solar installations in the
midwest our commitment to purchase these
renewable energy credits were key for
these Midwest facilities for them to
obtain the rest of the financing that
they needed to be constructed but we
would really prefer to keep this
development of renewable energy here at
home in New Hampshire where our dollars
can be reinvested in the local economy
but State neater statement net metering
laws have made this really impractical
for us so this is why we are such strong
proponents of Senate Bill 79 this bill
would enable us to install renewable net
meeting generators that can offset more
of our annual load the bill would ensure
that generation is size so that it would
not exceed our existing load as power
from a single generator could not be
shared across multiple companies or
other energy users and this bill would
also stipulate that businesses like ours
who are customer generators are actually
consuming The energy they produce either
on-site or under established group net
metering so we urge you to advance this
bill so that New Hampshire businesses
are able to invest in the generation of
homegrown renewable energy which would
support a stronger local economy more
stable and affordable Energy prices for
New Hampshire businesses and a more
sustainable future thank you happy to
take any questions
questions for Ms Lundgren
representative Corman has one thank you
Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question I I guess I'm a little bit
confused about
what your current options are
um
can do you actually have the the space
to
create more facilities at your location
or it would have to be elsewhere it
would have to be elsewhere we have fully
built out the footprint for buildings on
our site and we do not have a
significant land base around our
building and parking lot that would
accommodate a sizable solar installation
follow up
yes follow-up so so then where this bill
to pass
you would be able to would you be able
to build elsewhere is that is that what
it would be doing it would be allowing
you to build elsewhere or I'm unclear on
how this bill passing actually helps you
yes we can support the construction of
uh solar energy facility off-site that
would Supply
uh complete power needs for our
Londonderry facility
thank you would it also be possible for
you to accomplish your goals by signing
up signing a purchase power agreement
with a solar vendor to purchase solar
electricity from said vendor
yes but currently we would have to go
out of state to to find one that was
cost effective and we would prefer to
keep our investment in renewable energy
generation in state here in New
Hampshire
okay thank you
see no further questions I want to thank
you for coming to testify to us
thank you
could I ask Griffin Roe Berge to come
back up to the testifying table there
was one additional question that I
needed to ask you Mr Roberge
and that question is
Senate Bill 79 is virtually
identical in structure to Senate bill
69.
and Senate Bill 69 has a fiscal note
but Senate Bill 79 does not
in spite of that weakness has the
department done any kind of an estimate
as to how many additional
facilities might be
might qualify
we with if this legislation were to pass
for example in the 69 fiscal note you
estimated 65 entities could become
eligible if you've done a similar
calculation for this bill we thank you
for the question we have not the fiscal
notes are generated at the request of
the LBA office
obviously they requested a fiscal note
of us on Senate Bill 69 they did not
request one of us on Sam bill 79.
would it be possible to get that
estimate I could certainly ask yes okay
thank you I'd appreciate that
that was it thank you thank you you're
coming back
now we'll move on and I'll call on John
Morrison or maybe it's Monson
from hitchner manufacturing Morrison
thank you it is Morrison yes okay thank
you
good afternoon Sherman Vose Vice
chairman Thomas and members of the House
committee on science technology and
energy
my name is John Morrison and I'm the
executive vice president secretary and
Treasurer at hitchner I'm here to today
to testify in support of Senate bill 79.
the Morrison family has a long history
in New Hampshire first helping to settle
the town of Peterborough in 1749.
200 years later my great-grandfather and
grandfather bought a small Foundry
located in The amiskeag Mill Yard to in
my grandfather's words provide healthy
employment opportunities and build a
sound economic base in the state of New
Hampshire
today hitchner is headquartered in
Milford New Hampshire where it employs
600 people working across three
manufacturing facilities and one r d
Center
we produce high-tech investment cast
components for the global Aerospace
defense and Automotive markets
our customers include many of the major
Aerospace and automotive oems and we
produce components for most every
significant Aerospace defense and
Automotive platform
after 77 years and four generations the
Morrison family remains committed to its
vision of helping to build a stronger
New Hampshire
over the last five years hitchner has
invested nearly a hundred million
dollars in the state including in a
solar array and efficiency projects that
have earned over a million dollars in
utility rebates
as we continue to grow the business we
plan to invest another 100 million over
the next five years
to remain competitive however we must do
everything we can to control New
Hampshire's rapidly increasing energy
costs in a sustainable manner
while we continually find ways to deal
with the second highest electrical rates
in the country
our competitors in the rest of the
United States enjoy rates that are 50
percent or more lower than hours
as a major consumer of electricity this
puts us at a significant disadvantage
we're also under growing pressure from
our customer base to achieve lower
energy costs sustainably sustainability
is increasingly becoming a competitive
factor in all the markets we participate
in
this is why I'm excited to testify here
today in support of Senate Bill 79
extending the benefits of House Bill 315
signed by governor sununu in 21 to the
industrial scale business Community
would enable hitchner to offset nearly
20 percent of its electrical demand in a
cost-effective and sustainable way
this in turn would help us to remain
competitive as we continue to work
towards building a stronger more
Sustainable New Hampshire
thank you very much for your time today
and for your attention to this important
issue I urge you to pass Senate Bill 79
in support of the New Hampshire business
community and for the benefit of the
state itself
thank you questions for Mr Morrison
representative McGee thank you thank you
Mr Morrison for taking my question and I
believe I sent a thank you card to you
guys during the pandemic you were one of
my towns when I had a floaterial because
you were building you were doing PPE yes
that was one of the one of the many
things we did yeah yeah it was great
um so you're you're a good Steward good
citizen I
I would like to ask you you referred a
couple of times to uh the investment
that you made and the investment that
you are planning to make
um I'm assuming that's to reach specific
internal goals that you've set for your
company
um
would you say that the the lack of solar
uptake or support in the state has had
an effect on your plans to try and meet
those goals
yeah I think it's one factor I think the
overwhelming factor is the cost of
electricity and energy in general and so
for us
solar and Senate Bill 79 in particular
is is a potential Way Forward in
addressing some of those concerns and
short of anything else that's sort of
the best option on the table right now
thank you
so the inflation reduction act provided
permanent investment tax credits for the
installation of solar facilities
as well as substantial
um
tax
reductions in tax benefits
how do those compared to the relief you
anticipate from a bill like Senate Bill
well thanks for the question that's
that's very interesting question I I
think they're actually synergistic right
and so the ability to install additional
solar capacity would allow us to
take advantage of these tax credits more
more so than we can do today
okay thank you representative munz has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for coming in I'm looking at the um
the union leader article that you
distributed the the one specifically
talking about new study examines the
cost versus benefit of more solar I was
wondering if you wanted to comment on
that
I think it's
been widely commented on already today
but I think the gist of the article is
that
there are a lot of other benefits that
the the insignificant increase that's
been mentioned don't necessarily take
into account and I think those are
important benefits that we need to keep
in mind as we think about the the cost
of distributed energy
further questions for the committee
representative Reynolds has one
thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for being here today
um
those who oppose the expansion of net
metering
continue to insist that the
savings
that are realized by the owners of net
meter generation such as your company
and all the other these other companies
listed on one of your handouts large
companies they insist that those savings
that accrue to your company and others
come essentially come at the expense of
all rate payers but given the
scale of employment represented by just
these nine
these nine employers but all you know
other employers who could perhaps and
other institutions that might be able to
take advantage of expanded net metering
would you like to push back on that what
would you say in in to rebut that yeah I
think I can't speak for other companies
but in our case specifically I mean the
whole point of our company is is to
contribute to the economy here and so I
wouldn't really be advocating for
anything that I thought personally would
detract from that I mean
yeah I guess
the financial stability of our employees
is extremely important and so uh doing
something that would be profitable for
us at the expense of our employees is
not something that we'd be looking to do
so
thank you
further questions
seeing none I'll thank you for
testifying this morning or this evening
or afternoon whatever it is and uh call
Lindsey Burgoyne of revision energy to
give us her perspective on this
legislation
thank you and thank you for pronouncing
my last name right that is a rarity so I
appreciate that
um chairman Vos Vice chairman Thomas
members of the committee my name is
Lindsey Burgoyne I serve as the policy
and government Affairs director for
revision energy
as you well know revision is an
employee-owned company leading across
New England we have 100 employees in New
Hampshire and facilities and offices in
Enfield and Brentwood I'm here today to
share a joint letter that I should have
passed out
from the clean energy industry in
support of multiple bills that you've
heard today 68 69 and SB 79.
um as you've heard largely today in a
landscape of unsustainably high energy
costs Community scale projects give an
opportunity to provide lower cost lower
electricity which is a mission of our
employee-owned company the three bills
represent incremental steps towards
growing and enabling a local clean
energy industry here in New Hampshire as
they allow us to pursue projects here
that ultimately bring investment in
Economic Development to the state and
keep those dollars within this state in
full disclosure I'm going to share with
you all that today is my ninth day of
employment with revision I am new on the
job with the organization so I'm
respectfully going to close here I'm
very happy to relay any technical
questions you have to my co-workers and
to provide those answers in a timely
manner to you all so thank you for your
time today and as I mentioned happy to
relay any questions
well thank you and congratulations on
your new position
I hope you do well
so do we have questions from the
committee for Ms Burgoyne
well apparently not you did a good job
thank you thank you very much and I look
forward to working with you all over the
next years okay thank you
so that brings us to our last testifier
on Senate Bill 79
which coincidentally is our last speaker
for the entire day
so I'm sure he'll be mindful of that and
brief as Mr Sam Evans Brown
tells us about his perspective on this
bill
um I will be brief I will share I'm a
part of the crew that ordered lunch and
lunch did not arrive in time so I'm
suffering from an extreme blood sugar
low as we speak so um I want to get out
of here as much as everybody else
um I I just want to come up because I'm
I'm I would like to address a number of
mischaracterizations that I believe I
heard in the department of Energy's
testimony
um I think all the stakeholders that
have been working on this bill will be
very happy to fix any technical problems
with the bill that the department of
energy spotlighted I do think that some
of the the issues that were raised Merit
uh correction and I think they were not
intentional it's important to note that
the doe testified as neutral on this
bill in the Senate and it's easy to go
back and verify that so it is we did not
know that the department was opposed to
this idea until we walked into the
hearing room today
um and and I'm I'm frustrated to hear
mischaracterization of the value
distributed energy resources study the
what the study he found was that if we
were to leave the existing tariff
structure in place until 2035 the
estimated potential cost shift to non-dg
owning customers might be one percent
that's what the study found this is not
saying there's a one percent cost shift
today it's in 2035 there might be one if
we were to leave the Tariff structure
that we have in that we have now in
place for that entire time but of course
we know that we're not going to leave
that tariff structure in place for that
entire time because as you have heard
there's a docket that has been opened
that's going to re-examine the Tariff so
I would anticipate that by next summer
there will be alternate tariffs in place
and that may that you know when you read
the order that opens that docket the
main purpose of that docket is to make
sure that cost shift is not occurring so
I would argue that the Tariff structure
we have today is very close to the right
one and that with some minimal tweaks to
try to ensure that more of the benefits
that accrue to utilities when
distributed generation is interconnected
onto their grid are are actually aligned
with with the policy objective of
eliminating cost shift which you know I
have have some ideas and if folks would
like I can give you a preview of them uh
when perhaps I have eaten something
um
to lay that out though why does why do
net metered projects maybe just to go
back to basics here why do they get a
higher rate than the wholesale rate the
reason is that yes their cost the
utilities largely in the form of
decreased energy sales from those DG
customers but there also benefits to the
utilities as well in the form of
decreased line losses in the form of
avoided uh uh energy purchases
themselves in the affordable in the form
of avoided capacity payments all of
those are benefits that accrue to the
utility that are passed on to a
distributed generation customer in the
form of the net metering tariff that is
why on a bipartisan basis time and time
again the New Hampshire legislature has
sought to reaffirm that net metering is
a why is policy choice now could that
tariff be made better yes and that is
what the docket is about the docket is
not about
where are you know the geographic
restrictions on net metering customers
it's not about what type of customer
classes should be allowed to participate
up to up to five megawatts those are
policy choices that this body gets to
decide
so uh one other question that I heard
asked that I would like to address is
that 65 of the state's load is in the
commercial and Industrial sector so it
does not Senate Bill 79 represent a
dramatic increase in the amount of net
metering that's happening I would answer
that as no because uh this bill applies
exclusively to businesses that are large
enough to install five megawatts of net
metering on their own this bill as as
written does not contemplate sharing a
single five megawatt array between
multiple customers is only one customer
that has enough load in a single
commercial entity to have a five
megawatt array of which there are
relatively few in the state of New
Hampshire and you've heard from two of
them here at testimony today
so uh I think that's all I've got have
it take any questions if we'll have them
sorry about your blood sugar but
it happens
questions for Sam Evans Brown
representative Thomas has a question uh
thank you Monsieur thank you for taking
my question uh just the last thing you
said otherwise I wouldn't have a
question
um you said two industries that were
here today
would qualify for the five megawatt in
terms of having enough space
said they didn't have even if they did
have that load they hadn't load so that
the the bill as written is intended to
make it possible for them to install a
single array somewhere in the utility
service territory of the utility that's
serving them and for them to sign up to
be the off taker for that single five
megawatt array oh not initially space on
site but just a load to get right from
anywhere else and as I'm sure you'd hear
many industrial customers struggle with
having the space on site to offset the
load that they that their facility
represents all right thank you
further questions for Mr Sam Evans Brown
so he can get out of here and get
something to eat hands are shaking I
need a snacks so bad
thank you okay seeing done thanks a lot
Sam
and thanks to everybody who came today
to testify on this bill I'd like to ask
representative closure
to give us the blue sheet data on
Center Bill 69 and Senate bill 79.
now while he's doing that I'll close the
public hearing on Senate bill 79.
well
and 68 right so Mr representative
flocher can you give us 68 as well
yeah that's what representative closure
is about to announce
uh thank you chair our assistant did
provide 60. we thank her
um
Senate bill 68.
the blue sheet was seven in support zero
polls online it was 50 inch support zero
posts
Senate Bill 69
the blue sheet 7 in support
zero oppose
on line 44 and support zero posts and
Senate Bill 79 blue sheet was seven in
support
zero polls online 42 and support zero
post thank you chair
okay thank you so we're finished for
today I'd remind committee members who
will be back be back again next Monday
April 10th to hear some more Senate
bills and then we will return on April
17th to hear more and we will probably
exec some of those bills on the 17th and
any that we don't finish on the 17th we
will finish on the 18th representative
Thomas has an announcement
no just remind you to please collect all
of your trash papers whatever you had
here please take it off your table and
bring it with you